[Music]
a pickaxe shatters the rocky wall of a
mine shaft hundreds of feet below the
earth it's 1871 in a place that will
later be known as columbia county
pennsylvania men performing
back-breaking labor their hands and
faces blackened with dirt all working in
pursuit of that immensely valuable rock
coal it's the fuel for the booming
industrial revolution and much like how
dragons were said to guard gold this
more modern treasure pointed to an even
more terrifying monster a monster that
the scp foundation would someday come to
know as scp-1179
but these unfortunate and underpaid
miners had no idea what they were about
to discover one of the men working there
that day rob o'dwyer was hammering away
at the wall in front of him when he
heard something strange was that an echo
behind the rocks this could mean only
one thing the rocks in front of them
were hollow there had to be some kind of
space hiding behind them o'dwyer struck
again and again at the rocks in front of
him until the barrier finally tumbled
away he and the other miners suddenly
felt a gust of cool ancient air from the
vast and darkened cavern in front of
them sweep through the mine they felt
like they were standing on the edge of
something truly otherworldly as they
lifted their safety lamps high and crept
carefully into the dark it dawned on
them that they were likely the first
human beings to ever set foot here but
that didn't mean something non-human
hadn't gotten there first o'dwyer's lamp
soon found something in the dark a huge
figure curled into a crouching position
hiding its face it was made from stone
like an enormous yet incredibly detailed
statue of something almost human but not
quite the petrified thing had two great
horns on either side of its head
twisting into spirals like that of a
huge ram word of the giant frozen
monster hidden in the bottom of the mine
soon made its way back to the foreman
and then back to the mine's owner won
sean o'malley if it were anyone else
perhaps this news would have been taken
to the press immediately and the
foundation would have taken control of
the situation just as quickly but mr
o'malley was no ordinary mining magnet
he was a member of the molly maguires an
irish-american secret society whose
members were predominantly coal miners
in pennsylvania shawn and the other
molly maguires dubbed this anomaly the
sleeping stone giant and conspired to
keep it a secret between them as secret
societies have a habit of doing though
the molly maguires were disbanded less
than a decade later they were all sworn
to secrecy on the giant's resting place
until of course a descendant of sean
o'malley his grandson ian o'malley was
chosen as a prospective agent of the scp
foundation the foundation doesn't just
let anyone join their ranks they perform
an extensive background check on all
prospective agents both to find out that
they're capable of rising to the
challenges of the job and also to detect
any affiliation to enemy groups of
interest it was during this background
check that o'malley's subterranean
family secret was discovered and the
land above the old mine shaft was bought
up by a front company owned by the
foundation the sleeping stone giant was
finally incapable hands and in keeping
with standard procedure a research site
was built above the giant to gather data
and keep an eye on things at the time
the anomaly was considered extremely low
risk its containment file read
scp-1179 is apparently dormant encased
in the bedrock under research site apart
from simple monitoring and standard
research safety protocols no additional
containment is deemed necessary at this
time but of course those simple
containment procedures would soon need
updating in 1962 the town of centralia
pennsylvania had a trash problem there
were eight illegal trash dumping sites
across the town and to combat this issue
the town council opened up a huge
landfill in an abandoned mine shaft
you'd think this would be enough for the
moderately sized town but humans have a
tendency to produce a lot of trash and
they soon filled up the new landfill too
in order to address the issue the town
decided to do a controlled burn of some
of the garbage it should have been
simple enough but those who lit this
garbage fire didn't follow proper safety
procedures and ended up accidentally
igniting a seam of anthracite coal this
was like lighting the fuse to the
world's largest stick of dynamite and
fire soon coursed through the long
abandoned mine tunnels when the fireball
finally reached the sleeping stone giant
in this dark pit the beast woke up in
that instant an otherwise uneventful day
quickly became a brutal bloodbath
researchers walking through the base
felt a monstrous rumbling beneath them
heat sensors were burning up and seismic
readings were off the scale something
was climbing up towards them suddenly an
impossibly large sword speared its way
out of the floor killing everyone around
it with an immense blast of heat the
newly awakened monster went on an
underground rampage almost completely
destroying the research base and killing
nearly everyone inside before retreating
into the honeycomb of coal mines and
caverns in the area igniting even more
anthracite coal fires the foundation
needed to step in before things really
got out of control at present the
foundation couldn't properly administer
standard area construction protocols for
ketter class scps so they instead
designated the mines caverns and
surrounding countryside as area 179 and
dispatched mobile task forces to try and
contain the beast rampaging in the
centralia mines but much like the fire
that started this whole mess the beast
proved much harder to control than
initially imagined all five of the
expeditionary teams sent to apprehend
the monster failed and many team members
were slaughtered in the process from the
terrifying accounts of the survivors we
have a vague idea of the nature of the
beast below no pictures of the creature
exist and exact descriptions on the
beast can vary whether this is because
the beast frequently shapeshifts or
because it has some kind of
cognito-hazardous effects on those who
view it is unclear the most frequently
reported characteristics of the creature
are its immense height and the extreme
heat that its body exudes many report
that the creature's body seemed to be
formed of a mix of hardened lava pure
fire and burning smoke the beast
measures over 30 meters from head to toe
with shoulders over 8 meters wide it's
commonly said to have two huge ram-like
horns and a weathered bearded face the
beast has been compared by some to the
norse mythological figure sirter the
giant guarding the frontier of the norse
fire realm of mooseball however the
actual age of the creature seems to
predate these legends by a considerable
margin dating of the stratum encasing
scp-1179
indicates it dates to the mississippian
sub-period of the carboniferous period
approximately
359.2 to
318.1 million years ago this age is
consistent with the geological age of
this region so it may have literally
come with the territory less common
descriptions of the bees claim that it
has huge wings eyes made of hellfire and
fangs as long as a man's arm some say
that the beast has neither horns nor
fangs and its face is encircled by
flames which reach down into a long
beard of fire and like a certain
creature known as the balrog that lord
of the rings fans will be very familiar
with this beast comes with weapons in
one hand the beast wields a giant
burning sword around 5 meters in length
in the other it wields a huge
multi-tailed whip made out of fire it's
incredibly proficient with these weapons
too and has a serious strategic
advantage in its underground environment
foundation researchers have determined
that some of the wounds the beast gained
from its first confrontation haven't
fully healed implying the beast could in
theory be destroyed with enough
firepower however given that the beast
has killed almost everyone who faced it
and its mere presence can start almost
uncontrollable fires direct engagement
would only be used as a last resort even
the creature's breath can be extremely
dangerous chemical analysis of air
samples taken from
scp-1179's breath have shown
exceptionally high concentrations of
carbon monoxide and sulfur dioxide the
very presence of this creature creates a
real and active danger to everyone
around it and the beast presence was
beginning to have seriously negative
effects on the people up above by the
1970s the foundation had given up on
sending mobile task forces into the
caverns and instead began to focus on
depopulating the town of centralia to
prevent further fatalities from the
presence of
scp-1179 subterranean activities of the
creature were causing collapses in some
areas and noxious fumes were beginning
to rise up from cracks in the ground as
the constant raging fires burned beneath
the earth they were causing everything
above to slowly melt or bake a
foundation geologist determined that the
fires created by the beast would likely
remain active for 250 years and any
attempts to put out the fires or contain
the bees would ultimately be futile this
led to the formation of project tartarus
a concerted effort to cover up scp-1179
and fully evacuate the citizens of
centralia they pushed the narrative that
the mine fires while deadly were merely
the result of the failed garbage burning
plan and little by little the people of
centralia began to move away by 1984 the
united states government finally caved
to secret lobbying from the foundation
and allocated funds in excess of 42
million dollars to relocate the
remaining civilian residents from the
area any legal complaints from centralia
residents were quietly crushed by the
foundation and efforts to remove pretty
much all residents from the area were
successful this allowed the foundation
to finally cast a wider net and
administer kettier-class containment
protocols around the two kilometer
underground zone where
scp-1179 resides the foundation has
continued studies on the beast from
below in the decades since with some
scientists even suggesting it could be
used to produce geothermal energy but
whether or not that would actually be
feasible remains unknown for now
scp-1179 seems content to stay within
its zone and hopefully it stays that way
but as we're forced to dig deeper and
deeper for the remaining precious metals
here on earth there's no telling what
new dangers we might find lurking far
below the ground it was the summer of
2012 in damascus
and for the people of syria it certainly
seemed like all the predictions about
the end of the world were coming true
the syrian civil war was raging between
multiple rebel groups and the dictator
bashar al-assad whose government was
shelling its own people as well as using
chemical weapons and brutal campaigns of
violence across the country in hopes of
quelling the rebellion little did they
know amidst all this pain and bloodshed
something even more dangerous was
brewing an anomalous phenomenon in the
sunny plains north of damascus that may
pose a threat to all of humanity someday
a threat known to the scp foundation as
scp-13
the bone orchard this temporal and
spatial anomaly was discovered a few
years earlier in 2009 before the syrian
civil war even officially began it's
strange for a highly dangerous ketter
class anomaly to be discovered under
such seemingly mundane circumstances the
scp foundation first became aware of
scp-3989 after a small olive orchard
owner sold a strangely high amount of
olives that shouldn't have been possible
when compared to his reported number of
olea europea olive trees field agents
were dispatched to question the owner
about his sudden success but he was
resistant to questioning the agents
began a covert surveillance operation to
figure out what was actually going on
here at which point they discovered a
considerable spatial anomaly the olive
orchard was far bigger on the inside the
property was seized by the foundation
for containment the owner had no real
knowledge of the spatial anomaly it's
likely he just decided not to look a
gift horse in the mouth while making
money hand over fist from the extra
olives he sold the owner was given
amnesics and a new life as the
foundation began to study this anomaly
which was now labeled scp-3989
to this day no researcher has been able
to figure out the origin of 3989's
anomalous qualities it was first given a
euclid class designation and cordoned
off from the public with a simple
chain-link fence while foundation
investigations were underway on the
inside on a map the plot of land the
olive farm should occupy is about five
square acres but this plot contains an
unseen portal to a pocket dimension
within its 12-meter active zone which
doesn't follow the same spatial laws
that our reality does this sub-dimension
known as scp-3989-a
is a hotbed of fascinating anomalous
activity upon discovery of this hot zone
the foundation established the nearby
area 126 as a research center and a
makeshift containment facility for any
anomalous entities captured from
scp-3989-a
it seemed like the foundation really had
a handle on this situation but they were
blissfully unaware of the true horrors
lurking with an
scp-3989-a but they'd soon find out in
the most horrifying way possible dr
farah gazelli was assigned to head the
research into the anomalous zone within
3989 and naturally he began organizing
fact-finding expeditions into the heart
of the affected area the first guinea
pig to head into the hot zone was former
foundation agent josiah herrick who'd
been demoted to the lowly d-class
position of d-126-15
due to failures on a previous mission
with a remote link to dr gazelli herrick
was forced to venture into the active
anomalous zone to collect footage and
samples of the flora and fauna within
the first thing herrick noticed on his
expedition was the strange quality of
the olive trees within the active zone
the bark was a stark white and the
leaves a bloody red up close herrera
could see that the trunks and branches
of the trees had undergone a process
known as ossification where the material
slowly becomes bone or bone-like tissue
hence the anomaly's creepy name the bone
orchard these ossified trees became
known as scp-3989-1
herrick also made another discovery all
over the trees and ground were worm-like
creatures that looked like long maggots
that the foundation dubbed scp-3989-1
agent herrick then noticed something was
off about the leaves of the ossified
trees they were beating he looked closer
and they appeared to be heart tissue
filled with pumping veins dr gazelle
ordered herrick to take a branch for
testing and when he did the tree began
to bleed when he looked down he saw that
the worm-like creatures that covered the
ground were now crawling up his legs
ignoring orders from dr gazelli herrick
fled from the active zone in terror
as he left dr gazzelli caught something
in the corner of herrick's body cam
footage a long white hind limb
disappearing behind a tree back in our
normal dimension tests on the sample
hair collected yielded more upsetting
discoveries genetically the trees were
identical to humans the trunks were
human bone and the leaves really were
made of human hard tissue fascinated and
just a little bit horrified dr gazzelli
authorized further expeditions into
3989-a
this time though agent herrick would be
accompanied by another d-class and both
would be armed with handguns and
protective body armor as it would turn
out this expedition would be even more
horrifying than the first as the two
d-classes explored the active zones to
collect further samples they found that
the worms were responsible for the
ossification of the otherwise
non-anomalous olive trees they consumed
the wood little by little and deposited
human bone matter in return herrick and
his companion also noticed that these
trees were beginning to bear fruit dr
gazelli ordered herrick to collect some
of this fruit for testing but when they
attempted to remove the fruit it burst
releasing more worm creatures it seemed
that the converted trees acted as
incubators for their egg sacs before the
duo could return with the samples they
were able to take the creature that had
been spotted on herrick's body cam
during the first mission finally
appeared it was huge with long white
limbs and no facial features except for
a huge mouth it grabbed herrick's
companion and literally ate the top half
of his body in a single bite before
dropping his legs to the ground this
horrifying beast and the many others
like it would later be designated as
scp-3989-2a
herrick pulled out his sidearm and shot
the creature several times the creature
ignored the bullets though and charged
herrick the feed from his body cam cut
out soon after both men were declared
killed in action and in recognition of
his sacrifice josiah herrick was
posthumously reinstated to his old
position in the foundation job well done
agent dr gazzelli meanwhile prepared for
the next mission this time knowing of
the clear dangers present within the
bone orchard dr gazelle recruited the
help of mtf zeta9 aka the mole rats
three members referred to as charlie
team were sent into the anomalous zone
once again remotely directed by dr
gazzelli they were equipped with
experimental ultrasound technology so
they could scan the fruit of the trees
within
3989-a without breaking any and
incurring the wrath of
3989-2a which seemed to act as sentries
for the trees early on in their journey
they found the body of agent herrick
crucified against one of the ossified
trees his skin covered in mysterious
symbols that were likely of sarkic
origin while we don't have time to fully
explore sarkicism that will require a
video explanation all of its own all you
need to know is that it's a dangerous
religious cult that worships flesh and
disease and has close ties to similar
dangerous anomalies like
scp-610 also known as the flesh that
hates people familiar with that scp will
note eerily strange similarities to some
of the things the mole rats were about
to encounter as charlie team explored
they saw a huge number of 3989 2as
observing them with eyeless faces from
between the ossified trees they pressed
on until they discovered what seemed to
be an entirely new kind of tree within
the bone orchard
scp-3989-2 were huge trees made out of
what appears to be enlarged human spines
in place of a trunk the smaller twigs on
the tree were made from heart and lung
tissue and the whole thing was covered
in what appeared to be human amniotic
sacs charlie team attempted to use their
ultrasound scanners to discover the
contents of these sacks but one of them
exploded in the process releasing an
entirely new variety of monster from the
sacks emerged the larval stage of
scp-3989-2b
smaller humanoid monsters with no faces
no sensory organs two pelvises four legs
and an exposed spine suddenly charlie
team could feel a horrifying sarkic
presence around them which one member of
the team described as being like someone
grabbing her liver and giggling in her
face as the various monsters of the bone
orchard began to converge on the team
the voice of the sarkic prophet of war
and the hunt
began sounding in their ears he was
beckoning them to join him while charlie
team fled from the active zone dr
ghazali felt increasingly drawn into it
he heard the voice of orok and he liked
what he heard little by little the
workers of area 126 were losing their
minds manipulated by the sarkic power of
the bone orchard right next to them day
after day they were no longer loyal to
the foundation they wanted to serve
their new dark masters the fourth and
final expedition was led by dr gazelli
himself he took a band of loyal
followers and one non-believer on a
quest into the active zone to find an
orkian temple they believed was hidden
in the very heart of the bone orchard
once they were inside gazelle and his
loyalists murdered the non-believer as a
sacrifice to their new master they
carried on until they eventually found
what they were looking for a giant stone
temple resembling an aztec ziggurat
dubbed scp-3989-4
there they also encountered a new kind
of monster dubbed scp-3989-3
these beasts were larger than the others
and resembled ancient warriors they had
insect-like exoskeletal armor horned
heads additional hind and forelimbs and
integrated bladed weapons what dr
ghazali and his companions thought would
be paradise turned out to be a kind of
hell as they were led into the temple
where temporal and spatial distortions
broke their mind and the multiple highly
aggressive instances of scp-3989-3-2-a
and d-2b broke their bodies the whole
thing had been a horrifying trap in that
moment back at area 126 another fleshy
horrifying tree sprouted out of the
ground in the middle of the complex
monsters that had once been dr gazelli
and his followers emerge from its
amniotic sacs and all hell broke loose
throughout the complex
soon enough the base was crawling with
monsters from the bone orchard and staff
who'd become brainwashed sarkic cultists
working in service of orok humans were
gathered up to be sacrificed to the
ever-growing number of anomalous trees
things came to a head when the anomaly
in area 126 was visited by an outside
agent from the foundation working on
behalf of the hazardous materials
containment liaison biological
containment specialist dr marshall grant
and his team arrived at the site and
were horrified to see the sarkic
nightmare that had unfolded they quickly
engaged in a firefight with the
anomalous creatures and sarkic devotees
who'd gained control over area 126. a
number of dr grant's team were lost in
the process but thankfully they were
able to eventually regain control of the
base and the anomalous area after this
incident
scp-3989 was upgraded to ketter class
and given a huge upgrade in security
including four meter high concrete walls
and a platoon sized regiment of mobile
task force members with heavy weaponry
the force that took over the minds of
those exposed was designated scp-3989-5
a force so powerful that those infected
are given the choice to self-terminate
or be contained forever this may seem
like a somewhat happy ending to a grim
tale but one detail keeps dr grant and
everyone at the foundation who is forced
to deal with 3989 awake at night
according to all recent studies into the
bone orchard it isn't contained at all
in fact the active zone is getting
bigger
the year is 1941 and the world is
gripped by the most violent and
widespread war in history millions march
to war as bloody battles are fought
across the globe horrendous atrocities
are carried out on groups of people and
parts of london are bombed to rubble on
a weekly basis considering it's only
been 20 years since the last world war
it must seem to the early residents of
the early 20th century that the world is
coming apart at the seams and amongst
the chaos it'd be easy not to notice a
secluded manor house in the english
countryside disappearing without a trace
for 11 days before suddenly returning to
our reality but thankfully one
organization makes it its sole duty to
notice the unnoticeable and understand
the impossible the scp foundation and
within that anomalous manor house
foundation agents and researchers were
about to find horrors beyond even their
darkest imaginations this is the grim
tale of scp-1461
better known as the house of the worm
when the manor house reappeared after
its 11 day absence the foundation zeroed
in sending agents inside to investigate
it was a two level dwelling complete
with 12 bedrooms 4 baths 3 studies a
main foyer slash ballroom a library a
kitchen and a pantry basement the
foundation observed that a number of
these rooms had been fitted with rows of
bunk beds similar to a boarding house or
barracks only later would they
understand why they found that the upper
portion of the home exhibited no
abnormal qualities whatsoever but as the
agents investigated further they found
an entrance to the truly anomalous
portion of the manor the extensive
sub-level system no previous records of
the building kept by the local council
indicated that there would be anything
below the manor's basement so either the
mysterious previous occupants who were
nowhere to be found had built this
sub-level or had just appeared here on
its own regardless of which was the case
agents and researchers knew that
whatever had happened down here had
everything to do with the manor's
mysterious disappearance they descended
into the depths of what seemed like a
man-made cave system constructed
primarily from a mix of concrete iron
and brass it was a behemoth of 20th
century technology intricate snaking
systems of pipes gears and pumping
pistons it was like someone had built an
entire factory down here but for what
the agents began to spread out through
the labyrinthian vowels of the manor
hoping to find some answers but all they
seemed to discover was more questions
this place hadn't been built with any
form of comprehensible logic it was full
of dead ends stairways that ascended and
descended to nowhere doors that would
open to reveal just walls behind them or
not open at all it was like a maze built
by a maniac it didn't help that it
looked like the place was recently hit
by an earthquake with some passages
caved in and mangled machinery strewn
about it seemed that no human workers
had interfered with the impossibly
complex and bizarre machinery in quite
some time a number of the materials used
to construct said machinery as well as
the gray sandstone filling in the
collapsed passageways remain
unidentified to this day already the
sub-level was proving to be a complex
puzzle box with only an estimated 75
percent of its layout ultimately being
mapped by foundation researchers however
they would soon realize that this place
wasn't just confusing it was deadly the
only method of self-maintenance detected
by the exploring agents were pipes that
would fire a thick black lubricant onto
the surrounding machinery one of the
foundation agents had the misfortune of
getting covered in it while exploring a
darkened passageway and 80 percent of
his body was melted as a result it
appeared that the viscous black goo was
incredibly corrosive to all organic
matter a number of the machines also
emitted dangerously high quantities of
gamma and x-ray radiation making it
difficult to explore many of the caverns
without heavy hazmat protection and
worst of all were the extremely hostile
creatures living in the caves who would
regularly attack foundation personnel
these abominations came to be known as
scp-14
vicious steampunk frankenstein monsters
once human but with large parts of their
bodies replaced by crude mechanical
implants including metal teeth and claws
1461
have displayed a taste for human flesh
and they have dragged multiple
foundation agents down into their lair
to be converted into monsters like them
it's believed that
scp-1461 is capable of controlling these
beasts through the strategic use of
sound from its brass speaking pipes
leading them into areas where foundation
personnel are present to instigate
conflict many of these pitiful creatures
have had their throats replaced by
phonographs endlessly repeating the same
nonsense phrases over and over again i
am what you have made me i am choice and
i am tyranny forgive me i am then and i
am now what gods they will be then i am
evil and i am flesh i am the trap i am
beauty and i am chaos children are
selfish i am the worm i have broken god
still in spite of the mazes monsters and
deadly chemicals the agents persisted
and managed to discover several
important locations the gel production
chamber on sub-level 3 creates glass
jars from the unidentified sandstone and
fills them with a slime that looks to
contain living eyes and teeth the
factory deliveries room is filled with a
huge number of crates and boxes which
seem to shift and change in number
between foundation patrols the speaking
tube room on sub-level 11 contains a
grand pulpit that acts as the connecting
point for the complex array of speaking
tubes running through the entire cave
system the body parts of a deceased
female also appear to be wired into the
machinery like spare parts and on
sub-level 12 they found the so-called
catalyst room here they discovered a
huge complicated clockwork and
steam-powered machine that appeared to
be broken and missing some parts most
horrifying of all though is the raised
platform in the center of the catalyst
room on top of which is a metal hospital
bed a desiccated male corpse rests upon
the bed its chest punctured by large
syringes connected by tubes to some kind
of pumping machine the parts connecting
this pumping machine to the overall
apparatus of the room were missing
though leaving its purpose a mystery the
foundation assumed that fluids used to
be drawn out of this corpse to somehow
power the machine you may be starting to
worry that there doesn't seem to be any
answers here that this house is one big
mystery but lucky for you you're wrong
an old journal was also discovered in
the catalyst room and if what was
written inside is to be believed that we
may finally have some truth about who
created the house of the worm why it was
created and what horrible events
triggered its mysterious disappearance
and reappearance his true name has been
redacted by the foundation and special
efforts have been made to maintain
secrecy around the house seeing as it's
an anomaly of great interest to a cult
known as the church of the broken god so
we'll just call the one who made this
place the inventor before any of this
the inventor was one of the many
englishmen traumatized and almost killed
in the horrific trench battles of world
war one after a near-death experience
the inventor like many geniuses and
madmen was plagued by surreal and
nightmarish visions he saw a huge
creature that he referred to as the worm
a gigantic metal monstrosity with
dragon-like jaws full of gnashing gears
that rampage through europe destroying
and devouring everything in its path
these apocalyptic visions also presented
him with a solution vague blueprints for
a machine that might be the salvation of
him and others willing to take his new
gospel to heart and escape from a world
that the inventor knew in his heart was
about to end he hired work starved
laborers from across the country to help
him make his visions a reality and began
a massive secret construction project
beneath his isolated country manor house
for the inventor it was all a labor of
love he wanted to protect his wife
son and daughter from the terrible jaws
of the worm but as the project stretched
on his wife began to suspect that he'd
lost his mind many of his workers
however felt just the opposite they
became infatuated by the inventor's
sermons on the nature of the worm and
the coming apocalypse they hoped to
escape soon enough they had become a
bonafide cult constructing the elaborate
sub-levels underneath the house in
preparation for the fast approaching day
of reckoning then came world war ii the
inventor saw hitler hungry for war as
one of the avatars of the worm finally
knowing that the time was right he
activated the machine and successfully
trapped the worm in the bowels of his
mechanized home however as the blitz
raged and london's bombing began the
inventor felt as though he hadn't
stopped anything he realized once and
for all that he was never meant to stop
the apocalypse only escape it and by
throwing the final switch and setting
the machine he and his followers had
built into overdrive he did just that
this was the moment that the house of
the worm disappeared transporting the
inventor his family and his devoted
staff to a different world an empty gray
world devoid of war but also lacking all
the comforts of regular life including
food things went downhill from there as
their supplies quickly began to run out
and the cult descended into cannibalism
in order to survive things weren't going
much better in the inventor's personal
life his wife fearing what would happen
to the family took her own life and the
life of his daughter though by this
point the inventor's mind was so
fractured that it's possible he may have
killed them himself either way it was
only the inventor and his son left and
more trouble was brewing eudora one of
the staff trapped in the building with
the inventor and his cult started a
mutiny she claimed the worm spoke to her
from below and that their only path to
salvation was pleasing the worm how
would they please it a sacrifice of
course they would give it the son of the
man who had trapped it the mutineers
took the inventor's only remaining child
and descended into the lowest sub-levels
the inventor followed hoping to track
them down save his son and salvage
something from this nightmare as he
ventured deeper battling the members of
eudora's new cult he found that they
were changing themselves becoming the
half-human cyborg creatures that the
foundation would later discover the
inventor would find eudora herself in
the speaking tube room her body still
living was wired into the machinery and
she had sacrificed his son to the worm
in a rage the inventor murdered eudora
or whatever was left of her then heard a
familiar voice speaking out of a nearby
speaking tube it said i am what you have
made me i am then and i am now i am
choice and i am tyranny i am evil and i
am flesh i am beauty and i am chaos i am
the worm the voice was his own in that
terrible moment the inventor realized
that the worm wasn't a giant
all-devouring monster it was him in
trying to protect his loved one from a
perceived apocalypse he brought them all
to their horrible demise he'd trapped
them with the monster he'd hoped for
them all to escape from because no
matter what you build you can't escape
from who you are grief stricken and
broken the inventor descended into the
catalyst room there was his son stuck
with the syringes drained of all life to
fuel the mighty machine his father had
created in his last moments the inventor
decided to do the only noble thing he
threw himself into the machine
destroying both it and himself in the
process the house was transported back
to our own reality but the worm in a
sense was no more but who knows if the
worm is really dead its thoughts and
poisonous intent still lingers in the
caverns and rattles through the speaking
pipes whatever really happened the
foundation is still picking up the
pieces today and who knows what lurks in
the parts still hidden from our
knowledge
in a remote part of russia a mysterious
disease outbreak was tearing through a
tiny farming village with terrifying
side effects there was no cure no clue
to where it came from and worst of all
the disease's terrifying impact didn't
end with death
no
it was after those carrying the disease
died that the real horrors started after
an agonizing fever that leaves the
victims writhing in pain they quickly
succumb to the disease
only to rise from their graves to wreak
havoc on the living the virus continues
to spread until the corpses outnumber
those trying to hide from them as the
world spirals into almost certain ruin
it sounds like the plot of a zombie
movie but for the scp foundation this is
anything but fiction and the terror that
unfolded in that little siberian town is
the first recorded encounter with
scp-610
also known as the flesh that hates
first livestock began to vanish from
farms
after wild animals were suspected but no
suspects could be found and no mutilated
remains turned up the animals weren't
being stolen and they weren't being
eaten so what happened to them with no
more animals left to lose the farmers
themselves then began to disappear but
the authorities refused to take the
missing person's cases seriously the
missing farmers families would contact
the police make a report and then the
whole thing was forgotten it was written
off just as another unsolved
disappearance which wasn't uncommon in
the wild and unforgiving region then the
police themselves began to disappear
the families of the missing farmers
would sometimes report strange sounds
from the surrounding woods describing
moans and inhuman screeches of pain
one young boy reported seeing a cow with
what he described as tentacles lurking
around the edge of the trees regional
police were dispatched to the location
and ordered to investigate and report
back on their findings within 24 hours
but the units sent to the area didn't
report back and were never heard from
again
upon learning of the reports the russian
government grew increasingly concerned
fearing domestic insurgency or foreign
espionage of some kind could be at play
they sent a small team of special agents
to the area and one by one those agents
disappeared just like the others before
them it seemed no one who went into the
village after the disappearances started
ever came out again
they had all simply vanished desperate
for answers the russian government
contacted the only people in the world
who could help
the scp foundation what the foundation
found over the course of their
investigation would shock and unnerve
them going beyond anything they had
previously discovered before the
investigation officially began the
affected area was sealed off by the
russian government not knowing if it
would be safe to send researchers into
the containment perimeter the foundation
set up a small camera mounted unit
nicknamed herbie to capture footage of
whatever remained of the village the
images captured by herbie revealed what
exactly had become of the people in this
doomed village
and the true nightmarish nature of
scp-610
scp-610 is a ketter class entity meaning
it's an anomaly that's exceedingly
difficult to contain consistently or
reliably with containment procedures
often being extensive and complex 610 is
a highly contagious skin disease that
initially manifests like an ordinary
allergic reaction with symptoms
including increased sensitivity itching
and a rash but within just three hours
of those initial symptoms appearing the
rash starts to turn into masses of scar
tissue on the chest and arms these
masses spread over the legs and back of
the victim and completely consume them
in thick rubbery flesh within five hours
once they're covered the victim will
cease all vital functions unfortunately
for them and doubly so for those around
them they do not stay dead about three
minutes after expiring the victim's
vitals will restart at a heightened rate
and the masses of flesh encasing their
body will begin to move and multiply
mutating them into a form beyond
anything resembling the human they once
were the specific type of mutation
varies from case to case but has
included the head becoming massive in
bulbous the growth of extra limbs and in
especially gruesome cases the victim's
body splitting apart to allow extra
tendrils of flesh to sprout from the
open wound occasionally an infected
person will stop moving and become
rooted to the ground in a set location
once it is settled their flesh will
spread itself across the ground encasing
all nearby objects in flaps of scar
tissue the infected that maintain their
mobility are highly aggressive even
violent and will attempt to infect any
living thing that comes into their line
of sight the disease does not only
infect humans and can take over any
living organism within a matter of hours
due to the highly contagious and
dangerous nature of the disease safe
observation of infected specimens and
areas is only possible with drones and
mounted cameras
this brings us back to herbie the first
such mounted camera to record footage of
the infected area herbie was deployed to
an infection site also known as site a
without any damage it remained at the
outside perimeter of the village for two
hours observing several infected humans
and fire damage to many of the homes
before following an infected into an
intact house herbie's camera feed
captured the infected person entering
the house and sitting down at the table
inside there were several other infected
humans in the house and one unidentified
infected creature that remained immobile
under the table
after viciously assaulting one of the
other infected humans the infected
returned to the table and began to lay
out plates on top of it pieces of its
flesh began to wriggle and tear away
from its body before settling onto each
plate once the plates were filled the
infected sitting at the table began to
grab at the flesh and crush it into
their mouths in a perverse imitation of
a normal mealtime gathering after
capturing this stomach churning display
herbie left the house and continued to
explore the village it recorded footage
of a large stack of bodies that seemed
to be made up of both russian military
and civilians with an infected sitting
on top as herby maneuvered towards the
remains of the town hall an infected
grabbed the rover off the ground
herbie's camera was able to capture the
face of the infected that grabbed the
rover the face was that of a young girl
around 10 years old strangely intact to
top a large distorted body the final
moments of herbie's camera feed captured
the infected girl's face bursting open
revealing tendrils of flesh that pulled
herbie into the gaping maw
then the feed cut to black herbie was
regarded as lost but the video feed
briefly resumed five hours later showing
the camera covered with an unidentified
slime after this the video feed was cut
for good and herby abandoned in sight a
the foundation has sent several manned
expeditions into side a where many
expedition forces have fallen victim to
the infected several operatives were
also lost in an earthquake that revealed
a network of underground tunnels a
manned expedition into these tunnels was
attempted and the video feed that was
captured by the researchers on the
expedition was deeply disturbing there
were images of an abandoned church
filled with infected and a mass of
uninfected or partially infected human
captives
the final moments of the video feed from
this expedition captured several
operatives being murdered by an infected
human wielding a farming scythe
indicating that the infected are capable
of using simple weaponry in addition to
brute force the use of this weapon
paired with the presence of captives in
the underground tunnels
paints a terrifying picture of the kind
of organization the infected are capable
of no more manned expeditions have been
attempted or if they have they have been
highly classified ordinarily once a new
scp is discovered it is placed in
containment at the foundation with
special procedures in place so that it
can be studied or even neutralized in
the rare occasions where it's deemed
necessary when it comes to scp-610
though containment might just be
impossible it simply covers too much
area and is too dangerous to expose to
human researchers instead all infected
areas have been isolated with the
permission of the russian government
there is an official perimeter
established around these areas and any
civilians that approach them are told to
leave under the pretense of ongoing
military operations for once a
top-secret military project is the more
innocent answer armed guards are placed
at the perimeter of every infected area
and any living thing with symptoms of
scp-610 spotted near the perimeter is to
be immobilized killed and burned from as
far away as possible any living thing
that comes in contact with scp-610
whether a soldier a scientist or a
civilian is immediately terminated and
their remains destroyed if someone comes
within three meters of an infected
organism they will be quarantined and
remotely examined to determine if they
have been infected while the spread of
scp-610 can be airborne it has been
determined to be far less contagious
when spread through air particles as
opposed to physical contact
the infection sites remain active to
this day
like modern day leper colonies though
they are isolated from the general
population and the military is doing
everything in their power to contain the
infected
scp-610 is still very much alive it is
rare for an entity to exist that the
foundation cannot truly contain
but can only try to guard against and
that makes this infection all the more
terrifying who knows how much it has
mutated over the years growing spreading
hungry for new hosts there is still so
much that the foundation does not know
about the flesh that hates such as how
it works what it can do or even where it
came from since the origin of the first
infection is still at this point
entirely unknown it has shown itself to
be capable of learning planning and
protecting itself so who is to say that
it couldn't figure out a way to escape
from its isolated area
it is so highly contagious and spreads
so quickly that just one tiny infected
rabbit and one inattentive soldier could
be enough for
scp-610 to reach the general population
if it did its violent destructive nature
and hatred for all life would mean that
everything not just the people but
animals plants and the world itself
could be at risk
and no one is ready for this kind of
infection a disease that turns the human
body against itself
turns our skin into a weapon and a tomb
stripping away identity humanity and
everything that isn't made of the same
hateful flesh so let's hope that the
perimeter holds
and the next time you feel a little
itchy try not to think about what might
happen next
it rides against the snow
red raw and vicious too many mouths too
many limbs twitching and dripping
once it looked a lot like you but now
it's something different entirely if
ever it escapes its bounds it'll rebuild
the whole world in its image it is known
and feared by everyone with sufficient
clearance at the scp foundation and for
good reason it'll infect anyone and
anything and a death sentence is
preferable to infection it is a disease
that thinks the crawling corruption the
flesh that hates or if you fear its true
name too much to speak it and find
comfort in the categorization and
clinical eyes of the scp foundation
scp-610
scp-610 is a contagious skin disease
transmitted by direct contact anyone
infected with it suffers a horrific
mutation
turning them into fleshy inhuman
monstrosities
these infected creatures will attack and
infect anyone nearby that isn't also
carrying
scp-610 this also happens to be the
flesh described and adored by those
following the twisted religion of
sarkicism a violent cult and group of
interests that worships flesh corruption
and disease and as the foundation
operatives tasked with observing groups
of interests now sarkicism is a sect
that directly opposes the machine
revering church of the broken god and to
understand the events of the tale known
to the scp foundation as aftermath the
beginning that leads to its brutal and
world-changing end one must first
understand the endless conflict between
these two groups the church of the
broken god is a religion that the scp
foundation has had a number of
encounters with over the years members
of the church share in the belief that
biological flesh-based life is an
inherently wrong and evil abomination
they worship mechanization the process
of making organic bodies something more
mechanical in nature according to the
beliefs of the church two gods yaddabath
and meccan created humanity together
yaldabath was the god of flesh and
animal instinct granting humans bodies
meanwhile the god of machine and
intellect mccain blessed man with the
power of free thought as humankind
developed machines yaldabaoth became
enraged that they were ignorant of the
instincts she had given them and
endeavored to destroy the creations of
man as the church's legend goes meccan
acted as humanity's savior and tried
desperately to stop yaldabath the god of
machines shattered himself transforming
his body into a number of pieces to form
a cage for his fellow god fragments of
mccain rained down on planet earth now
the church of the broken god believes it
is their duty to recover these missing
parts there could potentially be
hundreds of pieces needed to rebuild
meccan and a number of these happen to
be catalogued scps that the foundation
is either aware of or has in containment
our story begins not with the
long-awaited return of mccain the broken
god instead it begins with a man a
foundation foot soldier named roderick
freeman this is the story of aftermath
in 2003 at the age of 17 roderick's
ambition was to join the u.s navy and
become a member of the renowned navy
seals after enlisting and completing
three years of rigorous training they
achieved his ambition only to climb even
further to high team never could have
foreseen in 2017 roderick now a seal was
recruited by the scp foundation after
his skills and aptitude caught the
attention of their embedded recruiters
he joined one of the foundation's mtfs
or mobile task forces elite units that
are often sent in to directly deal with
anomalous threats specifically freeman
became a member of mtf new 7 also known
by the code name hammer down the task
force you call in when literally nothing
else can do the job to bring hammer down
onto the scene for anything less than a
potential xk is like swatting a housefly
with a nuclear warhead sir roderick a
gunhouse soldier boy if there ever was
one would fit right in but what does
this mobile task force have to do with
all that talk about the church of the
broken god and the flesh that hates well
after an incident that broke out in the
irkutska area in russia they were the
ones responsible for cleaning up the
mess left behind according to roderick's
account a robot the size of a small
building was spotted in this area during
december 2018. this 30-foot tall robot
had apparently come to wipe out a
rapidly spreading disease as you can
probably guess that disease was
scp-610 the flesh that hates at first
the global occult coalition had fired on
the robot launching a volley of
ballistic missiles in an attempt to take
it down this move failed the robot
protecting itself so that not even a
piece of shrapnel could hit it it barely
seemed phased by the attack and went
about destroying remnants of scp-610 as
it found them any infected with the
flesh were obliterated and when its job
was done the robot simply left perhaps
this wasn't quite the grandiose return
from mccain that the church of the
broken god had envisioned for their
deity but it was nevertheless the
long-awaited return they got what had
happened was that the scp foundation
called a lifted veil scenario the truth
was now out the world would soon be
aware of the existence of anomalies
afterwards freeman and the rest of
hammer down recovered a series of
tablets that had been left behind by
mccain each of them bore a simple
repeated phrase in a variety of language
just the words i will return a short
time later riots began to spark across
the world it was a disaster too big for
even the foundation to cover up
according to roderick multiple anomalous
groups such as the serpent's hand and
the chaos insurgency had gone public in
mexico the insurgency became involved in
illegal businesses that gave the cartels
an anomalous run for their ill-gotten
money while members of the serpent's
hand used the air of tension to incite
riots in short everything was a mess and
this eventually escalated to a
full-scale civil war in mexico in 2021
during the build-up to this around 2019
there was unrest around the world and
mobile task forces like hammer down were
being deployed to train alongside
various public safety organizations all
in the hopes of getting the world
prepared for the storm gathering all
around them the insurgency and the hand
had revealed the truth about anomalies
to the world and so the foundation's
mtfs were aiding law enforcement special
forces and the like readying them to
defend against the anomalous in 2022 the
foundation finally decided to intervene
in the situation down in mexico where
the chaos insurgency and the serpent's
hand had been causing disruption
roderick freeman was one of those sent
to juarez coming face to face with
former cartel members turned lackeys for
the insurgency the chaos insurgency had
been fighting with the foundation for
decades and knew all their tactics
combine that with the ferocity and
brutality of a lifelong cartel member
and even the toughest soldier is in for
a fight as it turns out the fight wasn't
even the worst part for our dedicated
little soldier while attempting to
transport a person of interest across
the texas-mexico border roderick and his
squad were ambushed by a sniper during
the attack freeman received a wound to
his spine that left him paralyzed from
the hip down however even though the
foundation didn't like to admit it the
church of the broken god was actually
highly skilled in surgery after all they
worshipped mechanization and would often
augment themselves using technology or
to use roderick's own words if you
wanted an iphone in your skull in 2009
they could have pulled it off if you
wanted to be able to turn the lights on
and off in your home by blinking they
had an upgrade for that if you lost the
use of your legs because of a sniper on
a rooftop and juarez they had you
covered thanks to members of the church
there had been a new technological
revolution since the lifting of the veil
by 2024 devices that felt like they were
20 years more advanced than technology
should have been were now commonly
available so that's how roderick freeman
was able to walk again however the scp
foundation refused to let him return to
duty forcing him into an administrative
role frustrated he applied for a job as
a containment specialist meanwhile the
state of the world was constantly
changing with the scp foundation handing
over safe anomalies to world governments
new divisions and departments were being
formed to deal with the containment of
scps there was even an anomaly
registration program that allowed people
to call 9-1-1 to report dangerous or
life-threatening anomalies anyone
exhibiting anomalous abilities could now
find doctors or therapists rather than
being carted off to a containment cell
in short the foundation's days were
numbered however this was not as idyllic
as it sounds according to roderick this
should have been a chance for the civil
rights of anomalous people to be
respected something that the serpent's
hand had been campaigning for since
their modern inception instead it meant
that anyone with anomalous traits
perceived to be dangerous was arrested
as threats to national security things
were nowhere near as restrictive as
under the foundation the safer anomalies
could even have visits from family but
there was one boy thomas whom roderick
had to look after remarking that he
wasn't old enough to be kept in a
containment setting little did roderick
know the tests that were being run on
thomas were keeping tabs on him somehow
the boy was able to use anomalous
abilities to watch where roderick was at
all times the scp foundation was finally
disbanded in 2027
with the containment of anomalies
becoming the responsibility of the
global coalition council this
organization had long been the official
sanctioned counterpart to the more off
the books foundation despite their more
violent methods but now the goc was
making their work known to the public
but with the foundation gone roderick
was out of work picking up odd jobs over
the next six years there was widespread
criticism of the scp foundation and its
dubious methods the dark things they'd
done to keep anomalies contained
civilians killed entire populations
given memory wiping drugs to forget
about scps the horrific treatment of
d-class personnel a document containing
details about these practices and more
was leaked causing an outcry the scp
foundation's brutal methods were
declared to be crimes against humanity
alongside this paranoia about anomalies
was spreading governments were
encouraging their citizens to report
paranormal happenings and people with
anomalous traits were being registered
and arrested in roderick's account he
says when people don't understand
something one of two things will happen
they will try to understand it so they
can use it for their own ends or and
this is far more likely they will grow
afraid of it and try to destroy it so it
was when humanity rediscovered anomalies
former foundation employees were
declared public enemy number one with
anomalous persons at close second when
former members of the foundation began
to find themselves on trial by the
united nations the public began
executing any ex-foundation personnel
they could find at first local police or
even the national guard would intervene
but some eventually started actively
helping the vigilante mobs there was
nowhere for roderick to hide the fbi
even used the unusual incidence unit to
track down the foundation's remaining
members some had even been hired by the
uiu to bring in their former co-workers
and for anyone who knows how utterly
useless the unusual incidents unit are
to be brought in for execution by them
is a truly humiliating death unsure who
to trust roderick turned to agent
leonard wells a man whose life he had
once saved meeting at a diner in
wisconsin leonard agreed to smuggle
roderick to russia for five thousand
dollars getting him safely out of the
fbi's jurisdiction freeman agreed and
was then led to an suv with three other
men that he didn't recognize according
to leonard they were just there to help
smuggle roderick the five of them drove
to an isolated stretch of road only to
stop something was terribly wrong
leonard told roderick to exit the car
claiming that they would need to switch
vehicles as the suv drove off leonard
handed roderick a flashlight and told
him to signal a nearby grove of trees
and then
according to a report roderick x freeman
was wanted by the u.s government for the
actions he was involved in during his
time at the scp foundation he was
believed to have been responsible for
human rights violations and was picked
up by agents of the fbi's unusual
incidence unit the report claimed that
roderick engaged the uiu agents with a
small firearm although he had reached
out to agent leonard wells for help
whether he was executed or tried to run
away roderick freeman was shot and
killed but that was far from the worst
part about his death dying is bad enough
but witnessing death especially at a
young age is something that can have a
long lasting effect but who was there to
see what happened or rather who could
see without being there thomas the young
anomalous boy roderick had been assigned
to had seen the whole thing the world
had changed undeniably it has been said
that the foundation dies in the dark so
that we can live in the light but when
the same light was turned on the
foundation itself it seemed that they
couldn't survive under its scrutiny
either whether the world is better or
worse without them is something only you
can decide
there are some things human beings
aren't meant to know and it's the sworn
duty of the scp foundation to discover
and contain such information but
sometimes knowledge is discovered that
shakes even the foundation itself to its
very core one such discovery occurred on
april 28 2016. that night
scp-2935 made itself known to the
foundation personnel to this day the
exact nature of scp-2935
is a mystery that even the foundation's
brightest minds can't completely
understand everything we know about
scp-2935 today comes from three doomed
missions to the anomalous zone's
interior this is the story of those
infamous expeditions the nightmare began
around 5 a.m when scp foundation site 81
in bloomingdale indiana intercepted a
distorted radio signal communications
personnel at the site traced this
strange signal back to the
unincorporated area of joppa indiana
near u.s interstate 70. as is foundation
policy a team of field agents were
dispatched to the location in order to
determine what they were dealing with
however rather than finding anything
that could logically produce such a
signal they instead discovered a long
abandoned cemetery the most recent death
on any of the tombstones was recorded as
being over a hundred years ago all the
way back in 1908 on further
investigation the foundation discovered
an unmapped limestone cave opening
beneath the cemetery and when they sent
a drone into the depths of the cave it
appeared to quickly exit out the other
side of the cave but something wasn't
right the area that the drone was
observing appeared consistent with the
landscape from which it entered but now
it looked somehow grayer it lacked the
color of life of the place it just come
from the grass was dead there were no
trees no shrubs no animals or birds in
the sky they weren't looking at our
world they were looking at a strange
reflection of our world on the other
side of the cave in fact it wasn't a
cave at all it was a passageway between
two dimensions it was
scp-2935 just then they were able to
unscramble the distorted transmission
they'd been receiving it went as follows
this is an automated emergency broadcast
from the scp foundation and your
national government one or more of our
sites is experiencing a communication
breakdown likely due to a containment
breach of unknown magnitude all citizens
are ordered to stay in their homes as
containment teams work to secure the
breach this message will broadcast from
april 20th 2016 until at that point the
message would cut and repeat as it had
for eight straight days the message
source site 81 but not this site-81 the
scp foundation was receiving an
emergency distress signal from
themselves in another dimension a
bizarre event that even the foundation
had never experienced before field
agents were terrified by the
implications of what they just heard and
contacted site-81 command to request
additional units the foundation wished
to fully understand this anomaly as
quickly as possible due to the potential
threat it could pose toward the
foundation so they dispatched mobile
task force epsilon 13 codenamed manifest
destiny to perform the first of three
manned missions into the heart of the
anomalous zone the first exploratory
mission into
scp-2935 was codenamed gauntlet and
consisted of a four-man team fitted with
full hazmat suits and direct video and
audio links to mission command the team
was led by a field operative known only
as agent juno his subordinates were
agents kale devon and underwood their
directive was to gather samples and
survey the area position directly around
the insertion point meaning the other
cave mouth of scp-2935
the mission only lasted about an hour
but what they saw in there would stay
with these men for the rest of their
lives after a 15-minute trek through the
cave manifest destiny arrived in the
mirror dimension where they were struck
by the eerie silence of a place that
seemed identical and yet so different
from their home dimension the first
observation they made was the total
absence of all living vegetation trees
grass weeds everything it was all dead
on orders from their superiors back in
the original dimension that we'll refer
to from here on as dimension prime
manifest destiny headed deeper into the
mirror dimension of scp-2935
they traveled two kilometers without
detecting a single sign of plant or
animal life not even insects eventually
they came upon a farmhouse with two cars
parked outside with authorization from
command manifest destiny breached the
house and headed inside agent kale
confirmed that there was still power
flowing to the building as the lighting
appeared to work just fine but they came
upon a horrifying discovery in the
house's dining room three adult corpses
two female one male were seated at the
table a fourth corpse that of a male
child was sprawled out on the ground
nearby as if the death of what looked to
be an entire family wasn't awful enough
the manifest destiny team noticed a
number of other alarming details there
were no signs of decomposition on the
bodies nor did there appear to be any
obvious cause of death the family's last
meal was still on the table chicken
mashed potatoes and green beans while
the food looked cold and stale there was
no evidence of rot or spoiling the team
founded open newspaper dated april 19
2016 illustrating that the family may
have died a full eight days before the
discovery in dimension prime decay would
already be very well underway by that
point yet here there wasn't even a smell
instead everything was just covered in a
thin layer of dust command requested
that manifest destiny collect samples of
the food as well as hair skin and fluids
from the corpses for further study small
electronics like smartphones were also
taken from the bodies agent devin turned
on the television in the living room and
found that while most stations were now
running test signals the shopping
channel was still live well the feed was
live at least both hosts sat in front of
the cameras dead but perfectly preserved
the date on the screen read april 28
2016 suggesting that the times of
dimension prime and mirror dimension
were exactly the same in fact everything
seemed the same the only difference
between the two dimensions being that
some kind of mysterious apocalyptic
event had occurred in the last eight
days in
scp-2935's mirror dimension but exactly
what had happened or how remained a
mystery when manifest destiny exited the
farmhouse they once again remarked on
the lack of all signs of life around
them at this point the team returned to
the insertion point of scp-2935
but were instructed to remain in the
mirror dimension while additional units
joined them inside manifest destiny
swelled to 16 members with the notable
addition of agent roy as the new
commanding field officer the team split
into two groups of eight and agent roy
and his men infiltrated the mirror
dimension site 81 while agent juno's
detachment attempted to access the
base's off-site deep storage servers
this second expedition was codenamed
overland and led the foundation's field
agents even deeper into the terrifying
mystery of scp-2935
accessing the site was easy for roy's
detachment it seemed there were
relatively few cars on the road at the
time of the mysterious extinction event
in the distance fire still smoldered in
the wreckage of planes that looked to
have just dropped out of the sky agent
roy and his team like all scp foundation
personnel were fitted with vitals
trackers and they assumed that the
distress signal that started this whole
thing could have been triggered by the
deaths of every member of the foundation
at once in the mirror universe once
inside site 81 they realized that the
assumption was probably right going door
to door in the administrative wing they
found the perfectly preserved corpses of
everyone they knew to be stationed there
in dimension prime people who were
without a doubt still alive in their
universe samples from the corpses that
the foundation would later study even
confirmed the reason that the bodies
were perfectly preserved the corpses had
experienced complete and sudden death on
a cellular level and even the bacteria
that would typically take part in the
decomposition process had died with it
in scp-2935
death was total and absolute across all
types of life forms as agent roy's team
ventured further into the bowels of site
81 they made another unsettling
discovery their own corpses in roughly
the same spots they'd been inside
dimension prime site 81 8 days prior
some of the foundation's top scientists
including the esteemed dr bright were
also found dead inside the facility in
an attempt to see just how far this
unexplained phenomenon stretched agent
roy's team decided to inspect the
containment cells where they found that
all the mirror universe's scps including
scp-2996 were dead in his desperation to
find some kind of exception to the
extinction event agent roy revealed a
terrifying secret to the rest of his
team
scp-682 the immortal misantropic lizard
and one of the deadliest creatures known
to the scp foundation was contained at
this very facility right below them
could it have something to do with what
was going on here they descended into
the containment facility to discover an
even more unsettling truth scp-682 the
unkillable anomaly floated dead in its
tank death truly made no exceptions
within scp-2935
agent roy's team left the site and
rendezvoused with agent juno's team to
send their research back to dimension
prime using automated drones both teams
remained in the mirror dimension for
another manned operation codenamed 19.
they had no idea it would be their final
mission as they descended deeper into
the facility passing more dead scps they
discovered one final clue based on the
activity of the foundation servers the
event occurred at roughly 3 am while
underground in scp-2935
site 81 the team accidentally activated
the base's on-site nuclear weapon a
fail-safe meant to be detonated in the
case of an emergency containment breach
due to the base's fail-safe protocols
every member of the manifest destiny
team was locked and sealed inside
site-81 they along with everything else
were incinerated in the nuclear blast
once again the mirror universe inside of
scp-2935
was lifeless but that isn't where it
ends when the automated drones returned
out of the scp-2935
cave to the field operations in
dimension prime they were in for their
own horrifying discovery none of the
footage or information gathered from
scp-2935
illuminated how or why the extinction
event occurred everyone and everything
simply dropped dead at the exact same
moment nobody was aware nobody was
prepared death came suddenly and
silently and none were spared all the
foundation on dimension prime were left
with was a message from one of the
agents from manifest destiny agent
keller his final message was i don't
have any answers i don't think there are
any i'll do this one thing and hope that
fixes it seal it shut you've got to lock
it in here with us i'm sorry the
foundation were at first confused by
this until they discovered a final
encrypted audio log buried in the files
recovered from the mirror universe's
site-81 it was a message from keller
himself but not the keller from universe
prime in this message keller described
the foundation in the mirror universe
receiving the exact same distorted
transmission that they did a few days
earlier from a cave in joppa when he and
the others were dispatched inside they
discovered the same lifeless
post-extinction event world that was now
so familiar to the foundation command
but there was a key difference this
wasn't the mirror dimension they'd just
been studying but a third entirely
different dimension in his haunting
final words mirror dimension keller
admits that whatever caused the event in
that third dimension an entity in that
mirror dimension keller believed this
was the specter of death itself and had
followed him back into his world and
history had repeated itself
scp-2935 was the passageway through
which absolute death could pass from
dimension to dimension and our dimension
was the next in line the deaths of
manifest destiny may have saved our
entire universe as anyone passing back
through the cave had the potential to
bring death itself back with them the
foundation decided in the end to follow
keller's advice they sealed the entrance
to scp-2935 with concrete and now kept
it under constant watch since what waits
behind the barrier is an entity even
they have no power to stop if it ever
got through after all it had killed them
all before or at least another version
of them what's one more dimension on the
pile why it may now just seem like a
simple slab of concrete under an
abandoned cemetery this is why
scp-2935 might be the most dangerous scp
of all
shopping malls are one of the most
common locations in the united states
and are usually quite predictable and
boring so then why is the one mall near
havensbrook indiana one of the most
closely guarded scp foundation sites the
southwood park mall has been shuttered
with the mall encircled by fencing and
all entrances closed off foundation
agents under the supervision of
commander lana gray have standing orders
that if anything emerges from the mall
it is to be contained by any means
necessary or eliminated with necessary
force just what is lurking inside this
is scp-4971
a terrifying uncontained entity that is
capable of initializing a vk class
salted earth end of human habitability
scenario while
scp-4971 appears to be a standard closed
american shopping mall from the outside
what's inside is completely different
within the mall is a time-space anomaly
and anyone who steps inside will find
themselves in a massive outdoor climate
under a sun that looks to be perpetually
setting while the climate and flora in
the area appear to be similar to the
pacific northwest or yukon territory
testing of samples has been inconclusive
what is clear to those who have explored
this biosphere within the mall is that
it is much larger than the confines of
the mall and the limits of its territory
are unknown but those who wander in are
not alone and that's where the threat
lies the southwood park mall had
operated since 1985 but by 2006 the last
doors closed and the mall was left
vacant and abandoned the sign of urban
blight soon attracted trespassers and
criminals soon rumors began swirling
about the strange rituals being
performed by local teens while many
people allege supernatural doings no
proof was found that is until 2007. it
started as a standard break-in and
police were notified but as they
explored they started hearing disturbing
sounds screams and sounds that didn't
sound like they came from this world the
trespassers were nowhere to be found
this by reports that a huge group was
there the search eventually revealed the
portal to scp-4971
which appears at different places in the
mall and doesn't seem to be consistent
the foundation quickly compiled all the
information they had on the site and
discovered connections to a dangerous
group one of the people reported to
break in was katarina randolph a local
missing teenager with ties to anna
christian who was a known occultist in
possession of artifacts used in
summoning rituals both were members of
the daughters of eden a cult that
believed that mankind had disrupted the
natural order and magic must be used to
restore nature to its proper place the
foundation believed christian might have
been in possession of the last appeal of
bifi a text supposedly based on the last
words of a witch killed during a botched
exorcism many believe the texts had the
power to summon nature spirits to drive
away colonists while most copies had
been destroyed this one had made its way
from nazi germany all the way to miss
katonic university in massachusetts and
now it was potentially in the hands of
dangerous cultists while anna christian
was apprehended months earlier in a raid
on the daughters of eden the manuscript
was nowhere to be found and neither was
katarina randolph until she was seen
breaking into the southwood park mall
just before the anomalous activity began
while the book contains several minor
rituals the final one claims to summon
something called the one who knows
silence in the earth the entity bifi
reportedly called out for in her last
words a raid on randolph's former living
quarters revealed a rambling message
where she referred to herself as a
daughter of gaia and eden and vowed to
avenge the crimes committed against
earth and nature knowing these facts the
foundation debated on how to contain
scp-49
while they didn't believe the entity had
been summoned they believed it was in
process with the final ritual yet to be
completed a ritual that required a high
level of human sacrifice a team was
deployed consisting of code-named agents
there was the team leader eclipse fire
team roman and mercury science team
atlantis and bangkok and nine eyes on
communications they entered the closed
mall where there had been little
activity and turned on their lights to
see around the darkened facility it
seemed normal at first except for the
disrepair and vandalism but they soon
noticed something odd the mall didn't
smell like an abandoned building there
was wind in it and it smelled deeply
unpleasant as they entered the deserted
atrium they noticed the destruction
seemed worse than expected with a
collapsed skywalk that couldn't have
been knocked down by the vandals as the
team explored an abandoned clothing
store they encountered a humanoid figure
that seemed to be covered in thick
webbing like they had been the victim of
giant spiders who had planned to eat
them later and just beyond them three
unidentified figures lurked but didn't
move their eyes glowing in the darkness
they left the clothing store and decided
to watch if the strange figures would
follow them but they remained where they
were the team advanced into the mall
where they could hear the sound of
rushing water getting louder despite no
water in sight and it was clear that the
area they were exploring was far longer
than the southwood park mall should be a
sign on a store seemed to be written in
no language at all as the team entered
another large atrium the mall suddenly
ended and they found themselves in a
different world they stood atop a
massive cliff overlooking a forest that
seemed to extend forever the sun was low
in the sky and didn't move no matter how
long they waited the land seemed natural
except for a large symbol several meters
away it looked like a series of rings
surrounding triangles and small rings
carved into the ground an area in the
middle was burned as if it had been the
site of a fire and several glass vials
on the ground had been shattered but
most disturbing was the thick red liquid
filling the trenches surrounding the
symbols a quick analysis of the liquid
revealed it to be human blood further
examination of the site revealed an
altar a machete and pages from the last
appeal of bifi specifically the ones to
summon the entity described in the end
but while the ritual demanded a high
level of human sacrifice no bodies could
be found the ritual was governed by the
weight of the human heart sacrificed and
an analysis revealed that the 61 people
who had entered the mall and four
officers who went missing would have
reached a sufficient number to complete
the ritual the foundation was preparing
to bring in a heavy fire team to
eliminate the entity before it became a
larger threat but the team was skeptical
they hadn't seen any hostile presence
yet and had no idea what this entity was
even supposed to resemble they reported
their findings back to command offering
to bring back the manuscript and other
evidence but were asked to move to a
nearby water source and to hold their
position until the heavy fire team
arrived they hiked through the nearby
woods noticing an increase in
electromagnetic static that started to
mess with their equipment mercury soon
realized that they were being watched
while the other team members were
skeptical mercury insisted that five or
six entities were tailing them to the
east they started hearing odd chattering
unlike any known animal sound they
couldn't locate the entity on thermal
but it soon came into view it appeared
to be an animal but an odd flashing
light appeared around its head and it
kept appearing and disappearing as they
approached the river the sun which had
not moved for hours suddenly started
setting and it became abnormally dark
they tried to make contact with command
but the static had shut down their
equipment all recordings then cut out
simultaneously and contact with the team
was lost while the team was not
recovered the foundation obtained enough
information to put together a report on
the entity for the heavy fire team they
had determined that scp-49c
was the largest spatial anomaly ever
encountered being at least 400 000
meters in volume it seemed to be
self-sustaining and maintained by an
entity of enormous power the symbol that
appeared in the ritual was known as the
voxen eye and appeared in the last
appeal of bifi as the symbol she carved
into her chest it had been referenced
repeatedly in arcane writings and seemed
to have its roots in the pre-columbian
north american occult and it also
appeared to be linked to the one who
knows silence in the earth the ancient
being that took its payment in human
hearts it was time to send in the heavy
fire team the team consisted of team
lead horizon communications officer
aleppo and heavy fire agents vestige
cato carrier ashen and wild they
followed the original team who had lost
contact but was still transmitting their
location the foundation wanted to set up
a long-range transmitter that would make
it easier to communicate and set up a
permanent base inside the anomaly they
advanced into the eerily quiet forest
the sun back in its usual position as
they walked an unknown signal suddenly
came over their broadcast it was a song
broken up by static the girl from
ipanema the team was confused but they
would soon have much bigger concerns
there was a rustling in the woods and a
large group of figures emerged followed
by a single much larger figure it looked
vaguely humanoid but it was surrounded
by a tangle of branches vines and leaves
more disturbingly it didn't have a head
in place where its face would be there
was a strange bright triangle that
seemed to be vibrating in and out of
place the recorders became more and more
distorted as soon as this being appeared
the team tried to make contact with the
entity but it didn't respond they fired
their weapons and the creatures screamed
and collapsed against a tree the strange
symbol shattered while the entity seemed
to be dead their sensors picked up a mob
of figures moving their way they heard a
high-pitched scream over their earpieces
and they were surrounded by dozens of
similar entities the beings gathered
around their fallen member the team
heard an odd sound of breaking glass
mending and the creature rose from the
ground and rejoined its brothers and
started advancing towards the team the
team moved away but was quickly
overwhelmed cato fell and was overcome
by the creatures passion fell in battle
and wild lost in arm as the group fled
from the creatures aleppo's communicator
went off it was eclipse from the first
team contacting for help horizon made
contact and listened to instructions
that told them to head for high ground
the remaining members of the heavy fire
team headed for a nearby rise still
chased by the chattering entities the
ground under them shook and wild fell
behind and was snatched by the entities
in the end it was only aleppo vestige
and carrier that survived to meet
eclipse they compared notes an eclipse
said that they had been there for a week
trying to survive against the hostile
beings but the heavy fire team had
entered less than a day after them and
had been there less than half a day
something was wrong with the passage of
time but the team had barely any time to
reflect on this in their new safe spot
they heard intense static from the
radios followed by a low droning sound
their cameras broadcast a single still
frame of something approaching a
multi-legged entity and then their
communications cut out and both teams
were lost again additional recordings
were found from the survivors of the
first team led by eclipse detailing
their experiences within the anomaly
they reported being in there for months
with their rations running out while the
water was drinkable they reported it may
be making them sick the plants were
inedible burning their mouths and the
sun seemed to move only with their
movements they approached a mountain
seeking what they believed was a way
back home but as they approached they
encountered a mysterious figure that
appeared to be a naked woman dancing
near a symbol on the ground and a human
heart the team tried to contact her and
realized she was singing the same song
they had heard on the radio earlier it
was katarina randolph the missing
cultist when she turned around they
could see a large wound on her chest as
she ignored the team's orders nine eyes
fired and randolph crumpled to the
ground suddenly there was a surge of
energy and the team was knocked to the
ground a new entity appeared in front of
them a massive being with a deer-like
appearance but missing its head and neck
surrounded by glowing orbs and with a
massive white crest in place of its head
suddenly randolph's body lifted into the
air and the girl began speaking again
she called out to gaia claiming the
entity could have her and randolph was
transformed into one of the entities as
her head collapsed in on itself the sky
darkened and the team was lifted into
the air their hearts suddenly pulled
from their chests only mercury was left
standing running for safety he was
cornered by katarina pulled his gun and
the footage cut out one last time
scp-4971-9
had been discovered and it was one of
the most dangerous beings the foundation
had ever encountered an interview with
anna christian now in foundation custody
revealed that the creature was sustained
by rituals all magical rituals of any
kind human sacrifice gave it extra power
but it derived strength from everything
including the foundation's many magical
locks to contain entities stopping all
operations would weaken the creature but
would also endanger the earth countless
times over by the potential release of
the other contained entities it was
unkillable it was near impossible to
contain and it was searching for a way
out into the world and it was only a
matter of time before it found it the
good news is that there is a reverse
ritual but the price is high the last
appeal of buy fee contains a reverse
incantation that seals the portal to
scp-4971
but it requires a human sacrifice as
well and the cost increases
exponentially the foundation
investigated and discovered that the
cost would eventually increase to the
lives of every living being on earth
that had not already been converted into
the beings inside scp-4971
the scp foundation was faced with an
impossible choice here was an incredibly
powerful being that could end the world
and the only two ways to stop it both
posed an unacceptable risk to the world
the foundation met to discuss their
options and came up with a new esoteric
classification for the object sernunce
objects classified as surnuns can be
functionally contained but the
foundation cannot achieve this due to
logistical or ethical reasons therefore
scp-4971 remains within the southwood
park mall guarded by the foundation with
scp-4971 nabla inside and hopefully
contained there at least for now
london is the second largest city in
europe and underneath this bustling city
is one of the oldest and largest
networks of train tunnels in the world
but that's not the only huge old
structure located beneath the city of
london below even the deepest
underground metro stations of this
historic city there's a whole artificial
world of surveillance cyborgs impossible
architecture and stomach churning
nutritional supplements so be sure to
mind the gap because we're about to take
you on a tour of
scp-1678 also known as unlondon
scp-1678 is located one kilometer below
the city of london england from all
appearances it seems to be an exact copy
of the city though aesthetically it's
more in line with how it was around the
turn of the 20th century
gas streetlights stand on every corner
and the modern skyscrapers of the
business district are recreated in the
style of victorian architecture the
epicenter of construction appears to be
the houses of parliament which is
evidenced by the more unfinished and
flawed the city becomes further out from
the center one goes some of the
buildings are made of nonsensical
materials like copper pipes and some of
the gas lamps are nothing more than a
ball of disembodied light floating atop
a metal pole the first big question that
the foundation had upon discovering this
location was of course why on earth was
it created and they wouldn't have to
look far as an explanation of this
bizarre mirror city plays automatically
upon entering my fellow citizen if you
are hearing this tape then the world as
we know it is finished the sky has
broken the ground heaves with a [ __ ] of
terrible feet and all the horror and
madness from the dark corners of the
world has broken free to exact its
vengeance on the world of man evil has
raised its bloody flag upon all nations
of the world and crowd its unholy
victory to the broken sky yes this is
the end but there is a new hope welcome
to unlondon a city of survivors a city
of the free together fellow citizen we
will wait and prepare for the new
beginning the grand new world that is
soon to come let the world above burn
we will endure that the monsters have
the world we will prepare we will wait
and i tell you citizen that there will
be a new morning and you will emerge
from unlondon and stand blinking in the
sun and on that day citizen there shall
be a new order as we raise the union
flag over the entire world i welcome you
to one london the last city and the
first from this message it seems that
this mirror city was built to be a
refuge for survivors of an apocalyptic
scenario but the scp foundation had no
knowledge of such a plan in fact it's
still unknown who created this place or
how they did it the one fact that was
evident to the foundation was that even
though this strange place was intended
to be a safe haven it was far too poorly
constructed to actually act as one
illumination was unreliable and most of
the buildings were damp and infested
with mold it's also unclear to the
foundation where the oxygen and gas
supply of unlondon was coming from
throughout the day the loudspeakers
around on london play automated messages
such as no one is safe from the
influence of mimetic beings bryson's
home for the poor is here to help and
crime will not be tolerated in on london
the tormentors of society will become
its defenders at the end of every hour
that passes the speakers announced the
time followed by
and all is well when the scp foundation
first entered on london it was unknown
whether or not any living things
inhabited the city on first
investigation it seemed from its state
of disrepair that the city had been long
abandoned but soon the foundation met
their first inhabitant of the
underground city mobile task force
members were inspecting the area around
the houses of parliament when they
discovered what looked to be a bank as
they approached the doors they heard the
following announcement over the nearby
loudspeakers citizen you are entering a
restricted area have your authorization
papers ready a bobby will arrive to
escort you shortly this signaled the
approach of scp-1678-a
also known as the bobbies a single
instance of scp-16
appeared with the unmistakable sound of
a police whistle and as soon as it
arrived it started attacking the members
of the task force another announcement
came over the speakers police halt
criminal the bobbies are the main threat
to visitors in on london and they will
attack on-site with any improvised
weapon they can find true to their name
they are all dressed in uniforms
consistent with those of london city
police officers from the victorian era
what sets them apart from their
historical counterparts is their
construction these beings are made out
of human corpses crudely dismembered at
the joints and reassembled using metal
hinges and bolts with their heads
wrapped in bandages bobbies are
extremely hard to kill with only high
caliber rounds and explosive weapons
being effective at putting them down
autopsies of dead bobbies have shown
that underneath the police uniform the
bobbies all wear prison inmate style
jumpsuits this adds a chilling context
to the announcement about the tormentors
of society becoming its defenders it
appears that the bobbies are the
re-animated bodies of prisoners in
addition to the bobbies the foundation
cataloged two additional forms of
artificial life present within on london
first are scp-1678-b
or eyes in the sky hybrid biomechanical
birds made of flesh with an exoskeleton
of copper wiring some of these creatures
are covered in a deteriorating outer
layer of plastic and feathers suggesting
that they were originally meant to
resemble pigeons as their name suggests
eyes in the sky serve as a type of
surveillance drone and while they have
no offensive capabilities they still
pose a significant threat to the
foundation it's still unclear whether
they're able to communicate with or
summon the bobbies but the scp
foundation takes no chances the last
life form present in
scp-1678 is the strangest and the most
frightening as cp 1678-c
known as the wretch the wretch has only
ever been encountered outside the zone
which is now under scp foundation
control and it's uncertain how many
instances of this being exist the wretch
resembles an old woman or sometimes old
man dressed in filthy rags the wretch
sits at street corners holding a begging
tray and will attempt to elicit pity
from anyone who happens to walk by the
wretch will ask for food or money but if
food is supplied it will start weeping
before vanishing into a puff of black
smoke on a few occasions audio notices
playing on the city's loudspeakers have
alluded to this being saying do not pity
the wretch allow them to pay the price
of their betrayal for all eternity the
current foundation protocol with regards
to the ratch is to not engage with it at
all in addition to the bobbies the eyes
in the sky and the wretches there's
another strange component to the world
of on london throughout the city in any
area designed for human habitation the
foundation discovered multiple machines
that resembled modern gas pumps these
machines are fitted with coin slots and
rubber hoses that when coins are
inserted dispense a porridge-like
substance advertised as dr goody's
wonder food according to posters around
the city wonder food is a meal
replacement supplement supposedly
containing all of the required nutrients
for survival wonder food also appears to
be the only food source available in
london despite the claims by various
posters around the city that wonder food
contains all the nutrients you need and
completely restores health and vitality
examination of this substance has
revealed that it is much like the rest
of on london unsuitable for sustaining
life tests have confirmed that wonder
food is a synthetic starch gel heavily
enriched with various minerals vitamins
fats and bulking agents and it contains
artificially engineered dna helix
structures while it does contain all the
elements required for short-term
survival consuming the product for
longer than six weeks will result in
severe malnutrition and eventually
scurvy further tests have shown that
wonder food also contains psychoactive
properties the porridge contains a
mixture of unknown molecular compounds
which through regular consumption makes
subjects calmer less anxious and less
likely to resist authority it also seems
to have been engineered to cause
withdrawal symptoms that set in if a
person stops eating it symptoms which
include headaches and depression
foundation personnel are forbidden to
consume wonder food but the substance is
highly attractive to instances of
scp-1678-b and 1678 c like most things
in london the quality of wonder food
varies wildly with some dispensers
putting out a product that is so
degraded that it can cause sickness
deformities or even death in the
consumer but strangely the foundation
has also recorded a type of unknown
colorful mollusk which feeds on spillage
from the wonder food dispensers at
present on london is only partially
contained mobile task forces tau-4 and
epsilon 6 have succeeded in establishing
a perimeter around the hyde park
district where they have managed to stop
any incursion from scp-1678-a
even though this is the only area that
is fully under foundation control
explorations have been conducted of
buildings outside that perimeter the
investigations are vital for the
foundation's main purpose in on london
which is figuring out who built it and
exactly what kind of event this
underground mirror city was meant to
prepare for the interior of the natural
history museum yielded particularly
strange insights into the purpose of on
london for the most part the museum is
close to how it appears in the above
ground but with one key difference the
task force investigating the museum
discovered an exhibit called the fall of
man exactly where the darwin wing should
have been the exhibit as its name
suggests
details the apocalyptic scenario that
would have theoretically driven people
underground into on london but to
everyone's surprise its dioramas and
displays didn't depict an asteroid
impact plague or nuclear armageddon to
the foundation task force members the
scenes of destruction depicted in the
exhibit were far more familiar they
recognized the reptilian form of scp-682
the ordinary-looking brownstone basement
door that serves as a gateway to
scp-2317
and most chillingly the imposing
many-eyed figure of the scarlet king
these were only some of the known ketter
class scps depicted in the museum
exhibit it was clear that even though
the scp foundation hadn't built this
city whoever did knew a lot about the
scp foundation's activities it's
believed by the foundation that whoever
or whatever created on london still
resides in the houses of parliament and
the ultimate goal of the task forces is
to infiltrate the building but in order
to do that they will first need to find
where the bobbies are made and halt
their production it's believed that
bryson's home for the poor is where they
originate from but it's unclear exactly
where the materials to make them come
from nor is it clear just how they're
produced ultimately the foundation's
goal is to catalog the entire city and
once they have stopped the production of
more bobbies mtf tau-4 and epsilon-6
will storm the houses of parliament and
contain whatever force has created on
london but london is a very big city and
unlondon is just as big so there's no
telling what else they might find
exploring this bizarre location if you
have ever taken a trip to sun top
mountain in the mount baker snoqualmie
national forest washington state then
you may have come across an old wooden
structure the sun top fire lookout built
in the early 1930s the building was used
by the u.s forest service to keep watch
for any fires in the nearby woodland at
one point sun top fire lookout would
have been manned
365 days a year complete with a bed for
staff who were stationed there on
rotation the single-story lookout house
overlooks the scenic valleys of the
white river and huckleberry creek but
you're not here for an informative
tourist guide you probably don't care
about the frankly fascinating history of
the lookout and how it was used as part
of the aircraft warning service during
world war ii watching for enemy planes
no
you're here because something much
darker lurks inside the sun top fire
lookout and even though it appears to be
a simple one-story tall wooden structure
it certainly is not short on space
scp-3333 refers to an anomaly that the
foundation discovered inside the sun top
fire lookout house the building's
interior is a single square room
measuring 14 feet by 14 feet with large
windows on all four sides when standing
inside sun top fire lookout looking up
at the wooden ceiling one will
immediately notice a trap door no big
deal right a lot of places have a
ceiling entrance to a small crawl space
there's probably nothing behind that
trap door apart from a dusty old attic
there's a latch that maybe once had a
padlock there but not anymore opening
the trapdoor will reveal a collapsible
ladder should anyone be brave or indeed
foolish enough to begin to climb then
they'll soon find themselves right back
where they started inside sun top fire
lookout or so it will seem the thing
about being in a place like the mount
baker snoqualmie national forest that
surrounds sun top fire lookout is that
woodland areas are teeming with life not
just plants and trees but birds and
other animals of the forest you can
never truly be alone in a setting like
that there is always life everywhere
around you so when you ascend the ladder
and climb right back into the sun top
fire lookout that is the first most
noticeable difference you will find it
may take a while at first but the
nagging absence of something unusually
so abundant in a forest will eventually
become obvious it's quiet
far too quiet no birdsong or the sound
of distant calls from woodland critters
just silence
all around anyone ascending the ladder
will find themselves in a copy of sun
top fire lookout's interior one story
higher than the ground level of the
small wooden building with the stairs
leading up to the front door getting
taller each time to reach up to the
higher and higher building now you know
the scp foundation and the types of
bizarre interdimensional anomalies that
they're used to dealing with perhaps
scp-3333 is a mirror dimension or a
plane of existence where sound doesn't
travel it certainly seems to be
identical to the sun top fire lookout
say for the lack of any organic life
outside of course it's what you'll find
living inside
scp-3333 that you may want to worry
about climbing higher up the next ladder
and through the next trapdoor every time
with the same result you appear at
another copy of sun top fire lookout to
each one higher up than the last what
first seemed to be an innocuous
unassuming wooden building is now an
endless ascension up into the heavens
towards the unknown in silence without a
shred of plant or animal life outside as
you climb perhaps you start to think
about how much higher these copies go
this might even be the biblical jacob's
ladder connecting heaven and earth that
would be nice wouldn't it if you were
gradually climbing your way up to
paradise it might make it worth the trip
but
scp-3333 is nothing that pleasant you
wouldn't be the first to attempt this
long climb when the scp foundation first
discovered scp-3333
a research detail set up an on-site base
camp to examine this spatial anomaly
their first exploration involves sending
a member of d-class personnel designated
d-4f68a up the ladder his d-number is a
hexadecimal code that when translated to
text reads oh so we'll call him that for
brevity's sake during the first day's
exploration oh was able to climb 184
iterations of
scp-3333 communicating with head
researcher dr williams below on the
second day oh could see a pair of
figures standing motionless on a nearby
ridge but the pair could not be seen by
dr williams and the other researchers at
the base camp both figures disappeared
shortly after oh spotted them with the
camera he had been issued and he felt
uneasy almost certain that he saw them
point at him the next day at the 345th
copy of sun top fire lookout oh's
behavior started to noticeably change
previously he had been anxious about the
long climb and hadn't questioned
directions given to him by dr williams
now he seemed to speak more casually
resisting instructions asking williams
to climb back down and even calling her
doc instead of doctor oh also reported
seeing writing on the walls but there
was no evidence of this on his camera it
appeared that something had started to
affect him it was when o reached level
527 that things seemed to change more
dramatically rather than
scp-3333 continuing upwards the copies
of sun top fire lookout no longer had a
trap door or ladder they seem to be
arranged side by side in a grid-like
pattern stepping out of the main doorway
oh remarked on the lack of sunlight and
a walkway that connected directly to the
front door of the next iteration of
scp-3333
oh complained about the lack of natural
light and again requested to be allowed
back down dr williams instructed oh to
use the flashlights he was provided but
they wouldn't activate and their spare
batteries had vanished oh then noticed a
sudden movement and just then his
microphone and camera feed went dead
almost as if someone had turned them off
it appeared that
scp-3333 had something else lurking up
there dr williams oversaw the second
expedition into scp-3333
this time members of mobile task force
mod 0 also known by the code name
characteristic egg in spaces were sent
up the ladder they were sent through the
various copies of sun top fire lookout
were not as eventful as os with no signs
of mysterious figures or anxious
feelings that oh seemed to feel as he
climbed when they reached level 527
where the copies of the lookouts stop
progressing upwards and spread out in a
pattern instead their lights and
equipment all seemed to be in working
order however as the mtf team split up
one by one they encountered some sort of
anomaly or an effect of
scp-3333 that caused each of them to
vanish into the dark either that or
something took them these mtf units
reappeared confused in mod 5 the team's
leader graham purcell issued an order to
retreat and the entire squad went back
down the ladders for several days until
they finally reached the base camp again
the members of mod zero were adamant
they did not wish to climb
scp-3333 again but dr williams was
beginning to understand more of the
anomalies of facts it appeared to cause
abrupt changes to people's personalities
along with some sort of phenomenon that
caused things to appear and disappear
the higher one climb assuming these were
the result of a memetic effect dr
williams dispatched a counter-memetic
specialist for the next expedition this
specialist was a blind deaf and mute
woman known as a net or the null walker
who communicated via signaling system
embedded in her hand but was otherwise
immune to any memetic influences
observed by dr williams and graham
purcell at base camp annette made her
way to the top of scp-3333
reporting that she was aware of someone
watching her from outside the copies of
sun top fire lookout on her body camera
a flicker of motion occurred something
looking through the windows that ducked
out of frame when the camera passed in
its direction at the apex of
scp-3333 annette kept her flashlight off
but reported that she could detect blood
following it to what she assumed was a
body sounds of movement surrounded her
and as annette switched on her
flashlight williams and purcell saw that
it wasn't a body in front of her instead
it was a pile of rotting organs
decomposing muscles and discarded bones
and among the pile was a metal dog tag
that read mtf mod 5 graham purcell
the same man who was sitting next to dr
williams at base camp well the same man
on the outside at least the explanation
for everything going on inside scp-3333
all these strange occurrences and
disappearances finally came in a video
sent from dr williams's cell phone in it
a panicked williams covered in blood was
fleeing from something at the top of the
recursive stack of scp-3333
there was no memetic effect at the apex
of the sun top fire lookout copies
nothing was causing the people that the
foundation sent up to act unlike
themselves they simply weren't
themselves anymore according to her
frantic video dr williams had discovered
the truth about what else was hiding
within scp-3333
with just the right amount of vagueness
and intrigue the research team had been
drawn in it was as if they'd been lured
in by the lights of an anglerfish
realizing their grim fate only too late
the d-class o the mtf team even annette
had been replaced an unknown group of
entities on the top level of scp-3330
had been carefully observing them
waiting until they would not be seen to
slip in and switch places these entities
had been creating imagined anomalous
effects like oh seeing figures that
weren't really there
as a way of luring more bodies further
up the stack they wanted the foundation
to keep sending expeditions into
scp-3333
to keep them coming back the mass of
organs musculature and bones that
annette had stumbled across revealing
the ruse had once belonged 2 gram per
cell
before he was replaced you see the
entities residing in
scp-3333 weren't just copying people
they weren't possessing them or mind
controlling them or even shape-shifting
to steal a person's likeness
they were taking skin these creatures
hollowed out graham oh annette and the
mtf team pulling out their innards and
crawling their way inside filling these
fleshy puppets and leaving their
internal organs to rot these
hollowed-out people became vessels for
the entities of
scp-3333 to haydn the whole thing had
been a trap intentionally exploiting
human weaknesses
intrigue and unanswered questions you
know what they say about curiosity and
these entities used it to bring more
potential vessels to the top of scp-3333
they pretended to be the people who they
had replaced imitating them so the
foundation would send more personnel to
explore the tower increasing their
supply of skins graham's dog tag had
revealed the deception and dr williams
had escaped up scp-3333
the members of the research team that
had already been replaced were hot on
her tail determined to catch and hollow
her out too and by the end of her video
they had succeeded a month later though
a team delivering supplies realized what
had happened and the trap door was
sealed sun top fire lookout was put
under permanent guard but at least 50
personnel were killed or replaced by one
of the entities a new mobile task force
lambda 1 maxwell's demons was created to
hunt down and neutralize any of the
entities that had escaped scp-3333
but it's still unknown how many left the
tower and are still out there somewhere
waiting to use someone's curiosity about
the strange and unknown against them
scp-1730 is one of the biggest threats
the foundation has ever faced
scp-1730 does not exist it was june 5th
when the compound was first discovered a
large complex of structures in rural
texas about 15 kilometers northwest of
the mexican border located in big bend
ranch state park it was easily the
biggest structure in the area but there
was no record of any such structure ever
being built a massive network of power
stations containment facilities and
research buildings
scp-1730 looked like it had been
abandoned for a long time the exterior
was degraded but the building was still
operating a power generator had been
running for an indeterminate amount of
time even as the infrastructure degraded
power flickered through the site and
fuel leaked frequently but there was one
detail that attracted the attention of
scp brass
scp-1730 bore identifying markings
linking it to foundation site 13 a
research facility that was marked for
construction near gnome alaska but site
13 had never been built having been
abandoned in the planning stages so why
is it in the middle of texas fully
constructed and long abandoned the
foundation needed to know more and they
needed their best to investigate it was
time to call in the game wardens apollo
3 the mobile task force used to
investigate dangerous sites was brought
in and five elite agents were briefed
and sent in ross houston noah ohalo and
vigo it didn't take long for them to
discover that something was very wrong
with the site of scp-1730 the facility
was located in the middle of south texas
but the local flora surrounding it was
native to nome alaska something had
transported a building that shouldn't
exist to another place and time
commander ross ordered his men to enter
with houston taking the lead they
discovered that the entry led down a
long staircase they descended slowly
following a strange light that no one
could identify but had a sudden shock
when they discovered that the basement
of the staircase was missing the light
suddenly stopped and it became so dark
that it was impossible to see what lay
beyond the staircase upon probing the
inky black void at the base of the
staircase they determined it wasn't a
fog or shadow it was a liquid and it was
rising ross ordered the men to pull back
but houston was in too deep he couldn't
break free from the inky black liquid
the man pulled him away and got him free
but his legs were gone not ripped off
because there was no blood anywhere
smoothly cut off as if they were never
there and as they put houston down he
stood up on phantom legs he didn't feel
any pain but everyone could tell
something was very wrong with this place
and the messages they started seeing on
the wall made clear they weren't the
only ones who knew it what happened to
site 13 death here not my body bleed
there had been other people or things
inside scp-1730 and they wanted anyone
who entered to know that this was a very
dangerous place to be as they advanced
down the hall back toward the entrance
they saw what looked like a person in
the distance but as they approached it
became clear it wasn't another explorer
it was an old horribly disfigured corpse
seemingly attached to the wall not by
chains but views to the wall in
unnatural ways at first the team seemed
unconcerned recognizing the corpse as
someone named zachary fortunately
command back at the base realized this
as the effects of some sort of cognito
hazard a mental infection in the base
they uploaded a filter to their helmets
and the team recoiled in horror at the
site in front of them but the horrors
were just beginning they turned around
to see a shimmering humanoid entity in
the hallway behind him as it approached
its footsteps distorted the hallway
around it pulled ap-3 noah toward it
without touching him and as the soldier
was pulled into its clutches his body
started to distort viggo was next being
grabbed by the arm by a long appendage
and his arm started to change color and
distort but the foundation sent apollo 3
and prepared houston produced a portable
reality anchor designed to handle
reality warping entities and with a
flash of red light the creature was
revealed it was a horribly elongated
humanoid that only existed for a second
before the reality anchor erased it and
restored the hallway to its normal state
viggo would recover with the strange red
color in his arm fitting eventually noah
wasn't so lucky he was already dead had
been fused into the wall just like the
unfortunate corpse these horrors had
been encountered just by trying to
return to the entrance so it was clear
the only smart thing to do was to
descend further into the facilities and
get some answers as they advanced not
encountering any other supernatural
entities they saw more evidence of the
dark things that had occurred in site-13
the infirmary had been torn apart a
cafeteria had been melted into slag and
a large group of containment cells ended
with a section called olympia class but
while most of the other cells were
standard sized these were over 100
meters high what had the foundation or
whoever ran this place been keeping in
these cells they would get more answers
as they made their way down the hall
where they saw a single television still
working and illuminating the hallway at
first the television flickered but the
image soon cleared and the agents were
able to see what it was broadcasting it
was the interior of a containment cell
and there was someone in it and they
recognized them as one of the most
dangerous beings contained by the scp
foundation bobble the clown a predatory
supernatural clown that inhabits a
children's tv show bobble the clown was
broadcast by an unknown source and could
only be seen by children under 10
originally seeming to be a normal kid
show about a clown every episode
eventually devolved into the murderous
bauble teaching kids how to do horrible
things like arson and torture the
foundation eventually captured an
isolated bottles broadcast but the clown
remained hostile and vicious but not
here as the team talked to the bobble
trapped in the mysterious site 13 it
became clear that this clown was broken
by whatever it had experienced it
rambled and hid from the camera and it
was clearly terrified as it told the
team about the horrors of the site and
it seemed to recognize the agents as
something familiar but not completely
familiar it claimed to be able to smell
them and it said they smelled different
as bauble rambled on the agents learned
about a man named emerson who ran the
site like the foundation he was obsessed
with containing the strange and
dangerous entities in the world but
unlike the foundation he didn't just
want to protect the world from them he
hated them the entities in site 13
didn't even have numbers emerson wanted
to use them up however he wanted and to
dispose of them and something bobble
called the meat grinder entities that
outlived their usefulness were taken
down below and none were ever heard from
again it was directly counter to every
scp foundation policy but this site had
clearly been performing these horrible
experiments for years how and why hadn't
anyone heard of it the team continued to
make their way into the facility but
their signals were lost as they entered
the cryogenics unit by the time contact
had been restored they were no longer
alone there were survivors both agents
of the foundation and survivors of the
facility and they were angry with no way
out and massively outnumbered they
called for backup mobile task force t5
also known as samsara was reserved for
the heavy duty missions they're an elite
group of practically immortal cyborgs
fashioned from the flesh of a god and
equipped with further cybernetic
enhancements to eliminate keter level
threats and to protect themselves from
cognito hazards they were sent in
through a drainage gate to look for
survivors and neutralize whatever lay
within they didn't know what to expect
but they knew one thing no one who had
been sent in had come out it wasn't long
before they realized how dangerous this
mission would be as they came across
some large gated drainage pipes they
could see at least 20 charred bodies of
humanoids pushed up against the gate
some reaching their hands through
whatever had happened in site 13 these
unfortunate beings had been desperate to
escape as they made their way down the
drainage pipe they could feel it getting
hotter as if they were nearing an energy
source there was one other odd thing
about the pipe it was draining inward
not out they made their way into a
control room where many of the consoles
had been destroyed looking through a
window their view was obscured by a
mysterious black mass on the control
panels they could read terms like
incinerator and body pit access they
split up trying to find answers but
found many of their accesses blocked by
the black mass as the t5 task force
argued over their next move they were
startled by a sudden jolt the giant mass
had started moving the team watched as
the mass spun revealing a giant turbine
which turned the inky substance into a
fine slurry that was then scorched by
giant streaks of fire one of the t5 shot
open the glass chamber allowing the team
to be closer and blasting them with a
wave of heat as they descended into the
chamber they could see a massive
plant-like structure overhead which
started to shake suddenly thousands of
glowing pods were released from the
massive plant and each one lit up and
let the team view the chamber more
clearly but it was what was inside the
pods that was more disturbing each pod
had a humanoid shape inside seemingly
reaching toward the team until they hit
the slurry below and the shadows went
dark the team descended to investigate
the slurry when something started to
leak out of the walls looking at it they
could see something moving within one of
the team members picked up the wriggling
object out of the black liquid and it
took a bite of his hand it was a leech
and there were thousands more of them
moving toward the slurry consuming it
and as the leeches ate they started
growing they seemed to be moving in
unison communicating with a larger being
lurking at the base of the slurry a
larger leech a queen or something else
the team wasn't sticking around to find
out they beat a hurried escape from the
leech room finding themselves in another
hallway whatever the black substance was
the entities who had been here had used
it scrolling blood on the walls over and
over again occasionally they would come
across a drained corpse covered in the
black fluid and the leeches bled them
dry the facility was so sprawling that
the team knew if they wanted any chance
of navigating it safely they needed to
get the lay of the land they needed to
find the control center the door read
stairs to cryonics and the leeches were
nowhere to be found it seemed like a
safe path but as soon as the team
entered the temperature dropped
drastically to well below where it would
be safe for a human to survive the
team's internal heating system kicked in
to save their lives but it wasn't the
only threat the team was about to
encounter exactly what site 13 was
keeping locked up as soon as they
entered the room sound ceased to work
the filters in their gear were
overloaded and the team saw warnings
around the room silence don't look a
massive multi-limbed figure emerged with
each of its 60 arms moving independently
the creature had no head but a large
circular structure covered with ancient
glowing symbols whatever it was it was
ancient all-powerful and deadly the team
scrambled to get away as the glyphs on
the creature burned white hot anyone who
touched it was burned anyone who looked
too long at it felt their optical
implants burn out the symbols on the
creature were indecipherable but one
word was clear and printed in english
emerson site 13 was from another world
another timeline where the scp
foundation evolved into something
horrible ruled over by elliot emerson it
tortured and captured its beings and
eventually killed most of them in the
horrors of the incinerators when an
escape threatened to destroy the
facility emerson successfully activated
the device that removed the facility
from their world into ours of course as
any avid follower of the scp foundation
will know there's far more to the story
than this emerson may have been the
start of site 13's problems but he was
far from the end
it's the mission of the century a daring
rescue into the depths of one of the
most dangerous locations in the
multiverse site 13 otherwise known as
scp-1730 when the impossible site 13 was
first discovered multiple mobile task
forces were sent to plummet's depths and
none returned they were greeted to a
labyrinthine nightmare littered with
deadly cognitohazards escaped scps and
mysterious murderous leeches some were
trapped along with the civilians they
were sent to rescue others were killed
or changed in unimaginable ways mobile
task force apollo 3 also known as the
game wardens had been sent in on a
rescue mission when they encountered a
horrifying sight the captured broadcast
of bobble the clown a dangerous scp
known for corrupting and destroying
children through its deadly messages but
this bubble was different much like
everything from site 13 this bottle came
from an entirely different dimension and
he had terrifying information to relay
in the universe where scythe 13
originated the site's psychopathic
director one elliot emerson had struck a
deal with the global occult coalition a
controversial government group who
intends to protect humanity by killing
anomalies rather than containing them
emerson had converted his site into an
unethical unrestrained slaughterhouse
and was incinerating scps by the hundred
in the so-called body pit but emerson's
game of death came back and bit him
snapping the threads of reality and
turning the entire site into a
dimensionally displaced super anomaly
the game wardens realized they were in
way over their heads their chances of
surviving this place were dropping by
the second and if they wanted any chance
of succeeding in their mission they
needed backup so site command called in
mtf tau5 aka samsara calling in samsara
for a run-of-the-mill collection mission
is like using a bazooka to kill a
housefly but for a case as severe 1730
their skills were not only nice to have
but vital samsara are among the best of
the best immortal cybernetic clones
forged from the flesh of a god equipped
with weaponry and technology that could
surpass even that of other elite mobile
task force units the four members of
samsara are so adept at what they do
they earned the nickname power rangers
among their peers the remaining game
wardens knew that with samsara on the
case they may actually survive this
thing after all and they just needed to
hold out samsara arrived on site not
long after packing some serious
technological heat including arm mounted
incendiary cannons shock absorbing leg
extensions heat resistant plating and
built-in scramble adaptations within
their eyes to ward off the deadly
cognito hazards everyone involved was in
for the fight of their lives the four
samsara agents irantu nanku munru and
onru entered via a drainage gate in one
of the office buildings above ground and
began their descent inside after
observing numerous chart bodies they
deduced that there must have been a
massive incinerator somewhere on site
emerson's incinerator theorizing that
this was connected to the body pit they
kept hearing about they descended
further feeling the temperature rise as
they did so due to the anomalous nature
of 1730 nothing inside made any kind of
logical sense caused by a reality
warping machine known as thresher the
internal geography of site 13 was
subject to constant shifts the team then
split up to cover more ground moonro and
nanku continued to follow the pipes and
the heat toward the furnace while irantu
and onru broke away to explore what lay
beyond a weak wall after busting through
the wall irantu and onru explored
several empty office blocks before
finding their way into a control room
with a glass observation deck while the
window was obscured by garbage and human
corpses signage indicated that the
incinerator and the body pit were
directly below them the team once again
reconvened and managed to activate the
incinerator which shredded the mass
stuck inside with several large turbines
before burning the resulting slurry the
same process that had happened to so
many anomalies under emerson's watch
with the path cleared samsara decided to
descend via the incinerator using the
drainage pipe as a kind of makeshift
tunnel eventually they happened upon the
leeches large black and hungry these
creatures seemed to infect 1730 by the
thousand anywhere that blood or drainage
runoff could be found the leeches could
be found too they didn't appear to have
any connection to an anomaly previously
secured and contained by the foundation
they squeezed and wriggled through the
cracks in the walls searching for fresh
blood on root detected that the leeches
all moved with a kind of collective
purpose suggesting a telepathic hive
mind onru was able to tap into this
hivemind using her cybernetic
enhancements and mapped the chaotic
geography of 1730 through the leech
colony's collective knowledge with this
new advantage they could add a second
goal to this rescue mission find the
thresher device causing all the
instability and potentially reduce power
to it if possible but they were on the
clock to save the other survivors as
those leeches were sure to get hungry
for warm blood soon they followed the
leeches down the most direct path toward
the survivors on the way they
encountered a horrifying creature the
many limbed humanoid nightmare that
functions as emerson's eternal
punishment his charred body tied
screaming and alive to the platform
where the monster's head should be they
managed to make it past the monster
before finally rendezvousing with
captain hollis of mobile task forces 8-9
otherwise known as the molerats as well
as the game wardens and the other
survivors there were 27 surviving
members of site-13 staff many of which
had severe injuries making it even
harder to transport them back to safety
through the hazardous terrain and to
make matters worse the leeches were back
the team quickly decided that the best
route out of here was directly past the
thresher where they could reduce power
to the machine for just long enough to
create a stable path of escape nanku
opened fire on a horde of approaching
leeches with a flamethrower and everyone
began running for their lives it was a
final make or break dash to safety
however their advance was soon stopped
by a strange roped creature drawing a
cognitohazardous meme on the wall with
its claws when the team attempted to
engage it attacked exposing additional
deadly memes and the dangerous effects
of its single white eye and we're not
talking about internet memes here these
are symbols and information that are
often deadly to even bear witness to and
for uri this would be a real threat but
not to a team equipped with goggles
containing cognitohazard filter
technology the battle was cut short when
the floor collapsed underneath them and
the creature was devoured by something
even larger and more monstrous a
gigantic black bleach covered in huge
red eyes its entrance caused thousands
of leeches to spill out into the hall as
the monster screeched and slithered its
tentacles after them allow us to
introduce you to elijah also known as
the leech boy and a pivotal component of
the very existence of scp-1730 he was a
boy with the mind of a toddler but he
had the strange ability to absorb blood
through people's skin hence his nickname
leechboy one of the doctors in site 13
dr hadley took pity on elijah after all
he didn't choose to be the way he was
director emerson didn't share hadley's
sympathy his orders to exterminate all
anomalies included humanoids like elijah
when hadley protested emerson had her
beaten within an inch of her life while
other dissenters were shot dr hadley
disgusted by the inhumanity of her
superiors devised the perfect revenge
she sabotaged the incinerator and the
body pit allowing a mass containment
breach that flooded the site with deadly
anomalies young elijah ended up
consuming the slurry of the other
shredded anomalies causing him to mutate
into a powerful monster a behemoth of a
leech who gave birth to and controlled
all the others it was hadley's revenge
that caused emerson to panic and
activate thresher leading to a rift in
reality in the creation of 1730 and by
extension all the problems faced by our
heroes today samsara and the others fled
leach boy and began taking a different
escape route however while on route they
encountered the dreaded crystal
butterflies a dangerous scp capable of
destroying organic matter with a mere
touch irantu stepped up to bat roasting
the creatures with his arm mounted
incinerator and taking extreme damage to
his body in the process but they didn't
have time to rest with the butterflies
disposed of they kept moving heading
toward the thresher but not all the scps
were necessarily working against them
bobble the clown came in handy at the
next checkpoint manifesting in the
monitor of an electronic door and
opening the way through as they
continued on their journey they had to
fight off frequent attacks from leeches
losing some of the task force members in
the process they were also forced to
face off against a number of other
anomalies in order to survive such as
scp-2360
manifesting his floating bodies beneath
them and scp-1370 which used a huge
mechanized body to attack the team of
survivors that was all just a warm up
for the true final battle though the
floor shattered beneath them and out of
an impossibly huge chamber the monster
that had once been elijah wriggled free
reaching for them with huge tentacles
and shrieking from its thousand-toothed
maw it was at least 200 meters tall and
barely reacted to any amount of
firepower it seemed like they were all
doomed until captain hollis had a truly
crazy idea with the help of samsara she
led the bloodthirsty abomination down
through the cryonic center and into an
olympia class testing chamber there as
the leech boy was bearing down and then
hollis opened the gates to two adjacent
containment cells and something beyond
incredible happen two of the most
powerful scps ever known a giant
sword-wielding gate guardian and the
reality-bending cosmic deer scp-2845
entered the arena what followed was one
of the most epic showdowns in the
history of the scp foundation as the
deer and the gate guardian went to
battle against the all devouring leech
while the monsters fought hollis ordered
her team to get the rest of the
survivors to safety she and moonroof of
the samsara team remained behind to
prevent any of the anomalies from
escaping as the entire base began
sinking into the ground from the
combined forces of the battle raging
around them and the thresher's continued
onslaught on reality even if the
survivors escaped would the anomalous
developments inside site 13 escape and
wreak havoc on the world at large that's
when hollis received a vision a horrific
charred post-apocalyptic world roamed by
inconceivably powerful entities and
nightmare gods it was a vision so
horrific that just seeing it nearly
broke her mind she knew what she had to
do the only way she could truly defeat
this terrible place and ensure safety
for mankind while leech boy the gate
guardian and the deer continued their
battle for the ages hollis ran to
thresher and forced the machine into
overdrive up above the remaining members
of samsara the mole rats and the game
wardens escorted the survivors to safety
downstairs thresher emitted a blinding
white light as the system began overload
and her final moments all hollis could
do was laugh perhaps it was a laugh of
pure insanity of a mind broken by the
horror she witnessed or perhaps it was a
laugh of victory knowing that in spite
of the immense powers all around her she
had won the day she had saved not only
the survivors and her teammates but
possibly all of humanity and all it cost
her was everything outside the survivors
had reached a safe distance away when
the entirety of site 13 imploded in a
final brilliant flash when the dust
cleared scp-1730 was gone all that was
left was an immense crater where the
impossible base should have once been
captain hollis had done it through
overloading the thresher machine she'd
taken this anomaly out of the world the
exact same way it had entered it was
torn from its moorings on our earth and
kicked into the infinity of space-time
perhaps never to be seen again along
with everything it contained
scp-1730 was reclassified to neutralized
of course the foundation would have
plenty of other anomalies to pursue soon
after but the nightmare of
site 13 was over once and for all
a light shines above a metal table with
a chair positioned on either side this
is the isolated hermetically sealed
interview chamber of provisional site 23
outside the room awaits two
shell-shocked human mobile task force
members another with invisible ghost
legs three powerful cyborgs and a
scientist from another dimension they're
all here to talk about one thing the
nightmare that unfolded at site 13 also
known as
scp-1730 everyone thinks they know the
story a mysterious site suddenly appears
in texas seeming to exactly match the
blueprint for an abandoned site that's
supposed to be in nome alaska what
started as a simple anomalous location
turned out to be an epic horror from
another dimension the task forces sent
in by the foundation were either
massacred or trapped inside and those
who survived reported seeing unspeakable
carnage inside the base including a
death machine designed to destroy
anomalies and that's not all as a result
of the mysterious thresher machine the
entire location had been transformed
into a shifting spatial anomaly filled
with creatures straight out of a
nightmare from giant telepathic leech
monsters to huge multi-limbed demigods
that would eternally punish the site's
murderous director eliot emerson it was
only through the combined might of three
different mobile task forces including
the legendary samsara and the sacrifice
of brave captain hollis that the cursed
location was finally flung into a
different dimension neutralizing the
threat it posed to our reality but for
the scp foundation the story doesn't end
with neutralization there's still plenty
more questions that need answering and
that's why today we're going to tell you
what they found out after the
neutralization of scp-1730 not only will
we discover what's become of the many
people involved we'll learn about what
happened in the last moments before the
neutralization took place and perhaps
most importantly of all for the sake of
our universe we'll find out how site 13
came into existence and how site
director emerson went down such a dark
path it's time to get some answers
welcome to the final part of the scp-17
saga as we close the book on one of the
most deadly locations in the foundation
multiverse first to sit down in the
interview chair was captain ephraim ross
leader of the mobile task force apollo 3
also known as the game wardens he was a
shaken man looking far older than his 35
years his eyes heavy with the weight of
the horrors he'd seen and he and his
team were among the first to venture
into the bowels of site 13 and witnessed
the atrocities that had gone down there
like the body pit full of fleshy slurry
or the countless containment chambers
that mark their occupants for
vivisection and termination captain ross
was haunted by the things that happened
to his team under his watch as the
anomalous transformation of houston's
legs and the nightmarish warping death
of noah at the hands of a stretchy
reality bending anomaly he compared the
state of chaos going on down there to
something like jurassic park where all
hell had broken loose and the monsters
ruled he also remarked on the olympia
containment cells each the size of a
football stadium capable of containing
things far beyond the scope of this
universe's scp foundation his
interviewer was the hard-nosed dr peter
vincent who thanks captain ross for his
contributions and called in the next
interview subject agent leah mahalo a
game warden's task force member working
under captain ross he had a
thousand-yard stare and even the
untrained observer could see that agent
ahallo had left some parts of himself
back in sight 13. when dr vincent
attempted to interview him he mostly
remained silent only volunteering one
grim statement we should have died in
there this isn't real this isn't real we
were supposed to die in there next to be
interviewed was captain irantu of mobile
task force tao5 aka samsara his
interviewer dr isha st claire questioned
him about the nature of the mission and
the cybernetic soldier was even keeled
about the matter he said that in spite
of regrettable losses of life he was
still satisfied with the outcome of the
mission overall the high value targets
were rescued the anomaly was for all
intents and purposes neutralized and the
degree of loss was actually better than
their pre-mission predictions it seems
that the weight of death doesn't weigh
quite as heavily on those who will
probably never have to experience it as
the samsara team are capable of simply
being rebooted into new bodies if
terminated in the field people like
captain hollis weren't as lucky next
agent connor houston of the game wardens
was both interviewed and medically
evaluated by dr ian harris agent houston
had his legs dematerialized after he
tripped into a rising tide of anomalous
liquid which he described as looking
like a moving physical computer glitch
however in spite of this agent houston
is still able to stand and move of his
own free will it seemed to dr harris
that houston's legs were somehow trapped
between dimensions houston told dr
harris that he didn't experience any
kind of pain when his legs were removed
but to this day he occasionally feels
something furry brushing up against them
perhaps wherever his legs are they
aren't alone next the stoic agent
moonroo of samsara was interviewed by
captain elliot o'neal of mobile task
force d26 also known as time cops
captain o'neill had a bone to pick with
moonroo namely that he'd allow captain
hollis to run off and sacrifice her own
life despite having a clear directive to
prevent the human task force members
from endangering themselves at any cost
moonroo deflected claiming that when
hall is separated from the group he
assumed that she ran off with intentions
that never included her own demise
o'neill and the foundation found this
answer unsatisfying and decided to move
on to their next interview with onru the
last person with captain hollis before
her death the interviewer dr darian
arnold probed the elite samsara
operative on why she turned off her
camera before she and hollis reached the
thresher the machine that hollis
overloaded to annihilate site 13 from
our dimension she gave a more compelling
answer than moonro when she and hollis
entered the server room on the way to
the thresher they encountered what might
have been the ultimate cognitohazard it
was a vision of a terrifying alternate
dimension with billions dead a poisoned
star like the biblical wormwood fell
from the burning sky a nightmare god
like the one torturing elliot emerson
wandered along the fields of crucified
people covered in deadly
cognitohazardous ruins just looking at
it burned this scramble technology out
of moonroof's eyes and she quickly
turned off her cameras to avoid
potentially frying the brains of mission
control hollis wasn't so lucky the
things she witnessed broke her sanity
and when she finally overloaded the
thresher machine she was laughing and
crying finally and perhaps the most
enlightening debriefing interview of
them all site director william westerlin
interviewed dr mohamed scott the highest
ranking researcher of site 13 and
confidant of the now infamous director
elliot emerson the question was simple
just what had happened for site 13 to
become so messed up and dr scott
answered in detail with the tale of
corruption alternate realities and the
perils of unchecked power in his home
dimension site 13 was originally created
in nome alaska to house the corpse of a
giant sea creature that beached itself
on the border of india and bangladesh in
1964. it became the largest and most
secretive foundation containment
facility in the latter half of the 20th
century however disaster struck in 1994
when a marxist extremist used an anomaly
to level the willis tower in chicago as
a result the foundation lost a lot of
its funding and international support
leaving it in dire financial straits
enter the true villain of the site 13
story paul manafort if that name sounds
familiar to you it's because he was an
associate of president trump in our
universe who got into legal trouble for
shady international dealings however in
dr scott's universe he was a powerful
staffer for president bob dole who in
that reality had beaten bill clinton in
the 1996 presidential election manafort
was made the new secretary general of
the global occult coalition the un's
answer to the scp foundation and one of
their leading competitors with an ethos
geared toward killing rather than
containing anomalies manafort and the
goc co-opted the struggling foundation
providing them with money in exchange
for control the foundation had no choice
but to accept the deal with the devil
slowly manafort replaced the foundation
old guard with toadies and loyalists the
ethics committee and the o5 command were
dismantled dissenters were dragged out
of their offices and shot point blank in
the head execution style site 13 had
originally been directed by dr bright
but bright was arrested and contained
under false pretenses so manafort could
install a new director a mid-level
researcher by the name of elliott
emerson emerson is often painted as a
sadistic monster who took pleasure in
torturing anomalies to death and
flushing them down the body pit the
reality is both simpler and more grim
emerson it turns out was just an eager
yes man he was put into his position to
follow manafort's orders to a t and
those orders were simple kill in a
perfect example of the banality of evil
dr emerson converted site 13 into a
brutal slaughterhouse just as his
overlords at the goc had ordered him but
things were quickly getting out of hand
and one of the most vocal critics of the
new regime was one of emerson's old
lovers one dr vera hadley assistant
director of anomalous biology dr hadley
was disgusted by the inhuman acts
emerson was carrying out and couldn't
stay silent and for this she faced
horrific consequences corrupt guards
stripped her and beat her to within an
inch of her life in front of her
co-workers in that moment she swore her
revenge she sabotaged the containment
procedures and had the engineers rigged
the already unstable thresher device to
overload as emerson watched the
anomalies break containment he began to
fear for his life both from the
anomalies themselves and from the
punishments of his superiors at the goc
dr scott revealed that emerson was no
evil mastermind he was a lap dog for the
goc a dirty coward all the way to the
very end and he was desperate he held dr
scott at gunpoint and ordered him to
activate the thresher or die and the
rest is history there would be no
redemption for dr scott's former friend
as emerson ended up chained to the
rune-covered platform head of a
nightmare god for all eternity so ends
the debriefing of the site 13 survivors
and closes the book on that terrible
place for now anyway the story of
scp-1730 is anything but simple and
there are so many angles from which this
dark tragedy of cruelty and corruption
can be approached and ultimately it was
all for the same two things at the root
of every evil the desire for money and
power but the pursuit of these base
desires can lead to some truly
nightmarish consequences and nobody
knows this better than former director
elliot emerson who will be paying for
these sins until the end of time and
perhaps even beyond
site director tilda moose was staring
down the barrel of the gun that would
cause the apocalypse and
scp-6000 was pulling back the hammer
typically someone as important as the
site director of site 19 the
foundation's largest containment site
would never be put on a mission as risky
as accompanying mtf sigma-3 aka the
bibliographers right into the heart of
an active anomaly but these were
extraordinary circumstances to say the
least dr moose and the operatives of mtf
sigma 3 fire team chicago entered
brazilian airspace in late december of
the year 2030 below them an ocean of
trees the amazon rainforest known to
some as the lung of the world and the
lung had a cancer known as
scp-6000 director moose could see it on
the horizon beautiful and terrifying
like a huge shimmering scar on the
jungle's canopy it had been identified a
few days earlier via live satellite
imaging opening up like a wound in the
world's largest rainforest and it was
growing swallowing up and affecting
entire areas of land by the kilometer
not wanting to waste any more time the
foundation immediately sent in a recon
team to gather the first intel on this
rapidly developing anomaly once inside
the affected area known to the
foundation as the exclusion zone they
discovered unprecedented phenomena the
flora and fauna of the rainforest had
been altered drastically in the affected
areas trees appeared to be somehow
naturally carved into living bookshelves
their leaves tattooed with words huge
alien birds soared above the forest with
their paper-like wings also covered in
text spotted jaguars with six or even
eight limbs like a freakish
crossbreeding of animal and insect
lopped through the papery thickets and
hunt of word-covered prey every living
creature in the forest had been
transformed by scp-6000
and it was about to get a whole lot
worse if scp-6000 exclusion zone
continued to expand not only would the
anomalous effects prolong but they'd
increase in their intensity mutating
everything scp-6000 touched reaching
further and further across the landscape
the foundation needed to gather all the
intel they possibly could on this
emerging anomaly before it was too late
but time was beginning to run out just
as they began to gain traction the
foundation suddenly lost contact with
the initial reconnaissance team they
seem to have fallen off the map vanished
this triggered the immediate deployment
of subsequent expeditions into the
scp-6000 exclusion zone when the
bibliographer's first strike team
arrived on the scene of the exclusion
zone's bizarre alien world in search of
the missing reconnaissance team they
found the most strange and damning
discovery yet a creature who would soon
come to be known as scp scp-6000-a
much like the exclusion zone itself she
was both terrifying and beautiful
half-maiden half-monster a sleeping
woman with skin covered in scales her
legs replaced by the huge coiling tail
of a python she was reminiscent of the
mythical nagas or gorgons and thankfully
for all the mtf members in attendance
she was already in a sort of unconscious
state when they happened upon her
perhaps even more bizarre than the
creature herself was the question of
what on earth had been going on around
her she was found at the base of a
mutated tree already halfway transformed
into a bookcase there were several large
stones placed in the circle around her
each one covered in thaumaturgic symbols
written in what was presumably human
blood as though some strange ritual had
recently been performed but the most
notable detail of all was the fact that
she was surrounded by 12 corpses though
they remain unidentified to this day
there is one thing about the corpses
that was clear they were all wearing
dark robes it didn't take the
foundation's brightest minds to
calculate the connection figures and
robes performing strange rituals
anomalous creatures everywhere the
sudden appearance of a multitude of
anomalous books and the decidedly
serpentine entity this had to be somehow
related to the serpent's hand an
infamous group of interests that takes a
hard stance on defying the foundation's
secrecy and revealing the truth about
anomalies to the world while still
comatose
scp-6000-a was secured and taken back to
be contained in facility 57 while sigma
3 fire team chicago suited up and
prepared for their first trip into the
exclusion zone among them of course was
site 19 director tilda moose so let's
answer the big question on everyone's
mind right now why send someone as
important as a site director into a
potentially hazardous environment where
an entire reconnaissance team had
already gone missing and the serpent's
hand were believed to still be operating
because nobody at the foundation
understands the serpent's hand quite
like director moose after all in another
life before joining the scp foundation
she worked with them to the foundation
cooperative ex-goi members are worth
their weight in gold and in a situation
like this nobody could possibly be more
valuable than director moose she knew
the way and we mean that literally
all signs pointed to scp-6000 being the
largest and most unstable class w
gateway that the foundation has ever
discovered but you might be more
familiar with the concept of class w
gateways when they're referred to simply
as the ways the entrances into and out
of the wanderers library the legendary
extra-dimensional location that exists
as a nexus between various realities
that has become a kind of unofficial
headquarters for the serpent's hand
director moose had used the ways before
to enter and gain access to the
wanderers library back when she was one
of the hands but even she admitted that
she'd never seen anything quite like
scp-6000 when they touched down and
director moose first saw the environment
around them the shelves the books the
pages the text she felt a powerful sense
of deja vu it was just like the library
but something was wrong the way here was
not a standard dimensional doorway it
was more like a kind of open wound and
the wanderers library was spilling out
of it and into our world given the raw
cosmic power of the library it was bound
to twist our world into its own image
not the other way around there was only
one thing to do from here with director
moose leading at the head they would use
this vast new way to travel into the
heart of the wanderers library itself
and search for answers after all the
library is said to contain all knowledge
across the multiverse so presumably it
would grant them the solution they
needed to the scp-6000 dilemma they were
faced with but getting answers from the
library especially if you work for the
scp foundation is easier said than done
as fire team chicago made their way
further into scp-6000
they reached an area that director moose
could at least recognize as the true
wanderers library the dirk gave way to
wood paneling beneath their feet the air
shimmered like an oil slick mutated
trees gave way to giant empty bookcases
like they were witnessing the birth of a
new expansion as soon as they arrived
and began venturing through the
labyrinthian corridors of the wanderers
library the library's inhabitants took
notice surprised that the library has
some permanent residence don't be after
all you can hardly have a library
without librarians as only people with
experience like director moose know the
wanderers library has an enormous
contingent of creatures known as
librarians and archivists permanently
wandering their halls arranging the
books and protecting the location from
threats threats like fireteam chicago
the team had their weapons at the ready
when they first saw the creatures
appearing all around them director moose
noticed a giant red millipede skittering
around the hall past them an archivist
it didn't appear actively threatening
but its presence already was a bad sign
then a feminine hissing voice rang out
through the air it said i see your
intentions be gone something about it
communicated a dark and infinite power
and with that more nightmarish
librarians entered the scene huge
spider-like beings with countless limbs
class 3 librarians began crawling down
the bookcases towards them but there was
something different about these
creatures something even worse
they were wearing the uniform of the
reconnaissance team in fact once upon a
time they were the reconnaissance team
but their stories had taken a drastic
turn since they got involved with
scp-6000 something the rest of the world
would soon be able to relate to just
seeing this terrified moose it wasn't
unheard of for the library to transform
people into librarians but that was
typically a punishment reserved for
people who commit only the gravest
offenses against the anomaly what had
caused the wanderers library to become
so actively aggressive they didn't have
time to think about it because things
were getting worse as the class 3
librarians reached the bottom of the
bookcase they began to give chase
leading to fire team chicago desperately
fleeing the scene but they weren't fast
enough the creatures began to attack
tackling and slaughtering members of the
team the survivors fired back but this
led to even more aggression from the
librarians soon a group of class 2
librarians giant hooded beings wielding
lanterns began to join the chase what
started as a highly organized mission
soon became a massacre the foundation
operatives were hopelessly outnumbered
by the library's legion of obedient
monsters they could not fight and win it
was unlike anything they'd ever seen
before director moose was lucky to
escape with her life and in response to
the newly assessed severity of the
scp-6000 threat a wider barrage of
containment methods known as project
fusillade was initiated this meant
making facility 57 the official
containment site of scp-6000
this also resulted in the deployment of
active arrest warrants put on all active
serpent's hand cells as well as giving
mtf sigma-3 blanket permissions to
aggressively use any means of force
against the wanderers library's growing
aggression but trouble was already
brewing back at facility 57
scp-6000-a had awakened an attempt to
attack the foundation personnel around
it when it or rather she was safely
recontained director moose volunteered
to interview her first hand she hoped
that the creature might at least have
some information about what was going on
with
scp-6000 when the interrogation began
6000-a referred to director moose as a
jailer the serpent's hand expression for
members of the scp foundation from this
moose could easily recognize that 6000
had once been a member of the hand a
human too but she'd been changed into
her current form by a far more powerful
being the serpent the great entity that
rules the wanderer's library and the
very namesake of the serpent's hand a
being as old as the universe the queen
of all knowledge and a kind of god in
her own right in a sense director moose
had a standing grudge with the serpent
back when she was a member of the hand
moose was thirsty for knowledge she
craves stories but always frustrated by
the fact that they had to end she stole
sacred texts from the archive of the
wanderers library and ensured that she
would never truly be welcome again as
the interview ended 6000 promised to
continue looking through the stories of
the library hoping that the answer to
their struggles would perhaps be hidden
within meanwhile as scp-6000 continued
its aggressive expansion through the
amazon mutating and consuming more land
the efforts of project fusillades
subsequently escalated as well in one of
the largest coordinated efforts in
foundation history operation blackstar
mobile task forces on every continent
conducted a simultaneous raid on every
single known serpent's hand hot spot
worldwide and they found
nothing every single base was empty all
over the world not a single member of
the serpent's hand could be found it was
roundly concluded that they'd all
returned through the world's various
ways into the wanderers library like a
mother ship that was calling them all
home the serpent's hand the only people
who might have known what was coming
were escaping the planet as far as bad
signs go this was probably the worst one
possible the proverbial rats fleeing the
ship and if the library wanted its
servants to leave the earth it stood to
reason that the serpent had something
horrible planned for everyone and
everything left on it not long after
this director moose decided to deliver a
grim statement to the o5 council about
scp-6000
informing them of the gravity of this
new situation i don't know what
precipitated this but if the libraries
turned against humanity the situation is
going to be dire it's a completely alien
entity to us we can't even begin to
understand why it is or does the thing
it does how we don't even know if
there's a rhyme or reason to anything
most foundation personnel only know of
the library in the abstract but i and a
handful of others have actually stepped
foot in the shelves and we can tell you
that it is humanity's greatest blessing
and its greatest threat all at the same
time imagine how much history has been
influenced by people getting into the
library and bringing back knowledge they
would otherwise never have had now
imagine if the source of all knowledge
in the universe turns on us i don't see
this story having a happy ending in
spite of her grim prognosis director
moose couldn't give up in fact she was
relieved of her duties as site 19
director in order to pursue the scp-6000
case and subvert the library apocalypse
full-time seeing as it seems she was the
only high-ranking member of foundation
personnel who truly understood what was
going on she and the rest of the project
fuselaid incident committee scrambled to
find ways to destroy scp-6000 or at
least put a halt to its rampant growth
they sent in legions of mobile task
forces with flame and heat-based
weaponry trying to burn down all the
mutated trees however the trees showed
an almost complete resistance to this
method with burnt matter quickly
regenerating after the fact and an even
more savage act of war against the
wanderers library itself they fired a
high-yield explosive into the mouth of
scp-6000
however the second the bomb passed the
threshold into the library its effects
were immediately nullified these
concerning developments led to moose and
her team finally pulling out the big gun
literally the biggest gun there is the
arteris array a giant satellite-mounted
laser cannon only called in for the most
dire situations due to its huge
potential for collateral damage however
when they fired the arrays beamed down
onto scp-6000 at full power it remained
utterly unaffected these were just three
of the 34 different failed attempts by
project fusillade to put an end to the
library's rampage before it could keep
expanding and eventually destroy the
earth in a fit of desperation moose
returned once again to scp-6000-a
hoping she would have more answers they
needed a miracle to stop this thing from
becoming an xk class scenario at first
the imprisoned snake woman was cryptic
instead of giving moose useful
information she told her the true origin
of the serpent's hand they were once a
cult devoted to the serpent herself
warriors on behalf of knowledge
incarnate the modern serpent's hand
which claims to be comparatively secular
is little more than a shadow of what it
used to be but they still perform the
same basic task destroying secrecy and
advancing knowledge as moose's patients
wore thin she asked the snake whether
she had any specific stories about how
the foundation could beat a library gone
mad but the snake told her there were no
such stories she did however surrender
one vital piece of information saying
all the stories i see with the
foundation staring down the end of the
world they have the book burners by
their side i suppose there's something
to say there rivals allying themselves
against a threat greater than either
could imagine smoking ash a fusillade of
fire against a wall of trees
there it was
fusilade the namesake of moose's project
against scp-6000
which the snake would have no way of
knowing about this was it this was the
one narrative thread that could lead
them to their salvation but there was
one other deal that caught moose's
well-trained eye as well the book
burners better known to the scp
foundation and to you as the global
occult coalition one of the foundation's
most bitter rivals in the field of
combating the strange but this time
would it be worth putting aside their
differences to face the greatest threat
in their shared history could the
foundation and the goc together be the
fusilade that holds back the library's
terrifying advance once and for all
the o5 council held a vote on whether
the foundation should get the goc
involved after much deliberation the
motion was approved by a narrow
three-vote margin an emergency envoy
from the foundation was immediately sent
to goc headquarters in germany to invite
them to become a part of project
fusillade and stop scp-6000 expansion
before it was too late after
comprehending the full scope of the
situation and finally coming to
understand just how incredibly dangerous
scp-6000 was the leaders of the goc
approved this historic high-level
partnership goc physics psyche and
ptolemy division personnel were
transported to facility 57 for briefing
on the developing situation if they were
lucky they weren't too late to stop this
xk class end of the world scenario from
unfolding into completion interestingly
the goc prior to the scp-6000 incident
had actually conducted more successful
raids into the wanderers library than
even the foundation had so it was
natural that soon after they became
officially involved the o5 council and
goc command authorized another mission
into the library with goc strike team
9842 probable cause codenamed harbor in
order to discover more about the
situation from within director moose and
one of her closest associates agent adam
macmillan another former serpent's hand
turned foundation agent would instruct
the team via live video and audio link
supplied with state-of-the-art goc and
foundation equipment the harbor team
entered the exclusion zone they couldn't
help but remark on the extraordinary
sights before them a shimmering
technicolor fantasy filled with trees
halfway transformed into bookcases but
strangely all of the books within them
were utterly blank following the
instructions delivered by moose and
macmillan the harbor team advanced
further until they found an area where
the forest properly converged into the
library itself
much like fire team chicago had been the
harbor strike team was baffled to find
that this new expanding wing of the
library didn't seem to have any books
inside its endless bookcases the team
remained discreet as roving librarians
patrolled the halls and skittered about
high above them security in the
wanderers library had grown
exponentially eventually harbor found
the first book of the new wing a slim
volume entitled simply in progress much
like scp-6000's takeover of the world
outside but before they could relay the
knowledge within the book back to moose
and macmillan the voice of the serpent
herself once again sounded she asked the
two members of the harper strike team
why they were there and when they
claimed to simply be following orders
from their commanders the all-powerful
knowledge deity accused them of lying
the strike team members trembled in fear
moments later the two operatives were
claimed by the library much like the scp
foundation recon team before them the
signal link between harbor and command
was severed they were gone the
foundation in the goc's first joint
venture against scp-6000 had been
useless but that wasn't the worst part
the library's unprecedented
counter-attack was about to ruin
everything that the two groups have been
trying to achieve over their entire
existence
scp-6000 began putting out radio signals
but it wasn't just 6000 itself every
single abandoned serpent's hand cell all
over the globe suddenly began
transmitting and boosting the signal as
well it was too big and too coordinated
for even the combined efforts of the
foundation and the coalition to get a
handle on the signal was the voice of
the serpent herself hissing the garden
is the serpent's place and a lot of
people heard it governments
organizations and individuals all over
the world picked up the signal and its
ultimate source the amazon rainforest as
millions of people began to turn their
attention to the amazon their eyes were
drawn to one thing scp-6000
and its enormous shimmering oil slick
expanding out over the canopy too big
now for the foundation and the goc to
keep under wraps anymore the internet
blew up with millions of posts and
messages across every platform
imaginable even the foundation's web
crawler was utterly overwhelmed one form
poster said you guys see the pictures
coming out of brazil msn's probably
gonna get a hold of it by tomorrow and
suppress the story but it's insane i
have no clue what the hell is going on
in the amazon but the pictures make it
look like some sort of oil slick it's
kind of beautiful another commented yep
turns out i'm not nuts my friends have
been hearing it on their car radios and
hams too a woman's voice sort of nasally
repeating numbers and coordinates i
think in the words the garden is the
serpent's place sounds biblical maybe a
passphrase of some sort now here's the
kicker if you look on google earth or
anything for the coordinates
everything's fine it doesn't show
anything out of the ordinary but if you
use a back door to get into the wildlife
observation camera scattered around the
cameras went offline immediately after
but i managed to save this image
starting to think i should go down there
this could be big but random people on
the internet were just the tip of the
iceberg it didn't take long for all the
classified information about scp-6000 to
fall into the hands of a number of
mainstream media outlets the wall street
journal ran it with the headline the
amazon anomaly not long after the
guardian released brazil under lockdown
as the efforts of the foundation and the
goc to keep a lid on things started to
look more like a military coup than a
routine quarantine effort the horrors
started to snowball news about the
strange activity in the amazon led to a
massive influx of tourists and amateur
investigators attempting to gain access
while the foundation and the goc did
what they could to hold people off and
provide amnesics to those who were
actually exposed it wasn't enough the
cat was out of the bag and now any
attempts to cover up what had already
been released felt like just another
element of the conspiracy knowledge was
spreading fast and then trying to cover
it up both the foundation and the goc
risked exposing even their own
existences to the public in the process
the serpent's plan had been working
perfectly it seemed but this was more
than a mere compromise of informational
security the increased global knowledge
of scp-6000 seemed to massively increase
its expansion as though it fed on
people's knowledge of it the exclusion
zone grew by a terrifying six kilometers
and the mutations within its boundaries
only seemed to intensify things that had
gotten so severe that the coalition's
nuclear resources were being considered
as a response to scp-6000's aggression
not long after this director moose's
closest confidant within project
fusillade agent macmillan disappeared
security footage of facility 57 showed
him performing a thamaturgic ritual
circle similar to the one that had
produced scp-6000-a
the cameras captured an intense flash of
light from the circle and afterwards
macmillan was gone he left a note for
director moose saying sorry tilly i used
to spend weeks amongst the library
shelves perusing everything i could come
across it was otherworldly in the most
literal sense of the word i'm sure you
understand the feeling the difference is
that you couldn't go in you made the
choice between the library and the
foundation when i first entered it was
just a mission i experienced something
amazing something well beyond what i
thought was ever possible and i thought
it was a shame that we looked at
something so magnificent and only
worried about how it might hurt us i can
see now that's not the case the
librarians are only hurting people that
try to stop the expansion i have no
intention of doing that this is the end
of the story not the one where we
somehow come up with a silver bullet to
fix everything the only thing i can do
is change how i feel about it i just
want to sit amongst the shelves and see
the false stars again i think this is my
happy ending director moose certainly
didn't see it that way in spite of
everything she was still desperately
searching for that elusive silver bullet
the secret to stopping scp-6000 and
reversing the horrific damage it had
already wrought they were the scp
foundation they always found a solution
it was just a matter of looking harder
for it she returned once again to her
last potential resource on the matter
scp-6000-a that cryptic snake woman
they'd first discovered in the initial
recon missions into scp-6000
in many ways
scp-6000-a echoed the sentiments of
agent macmillan to deny true fate is
futile just this once the foundation had
run out of silver bullets their end was
coming perfect and inevitable and it
will happen at the hands of the library
and the serpent she told director moose
that you don't get to choose how your
stories end only how you perceive the
ending this story she says ends with two
people sitting in a room talking and
they vanish into thin air tired of the
snake woman's cryptic nonsense
director moose decided she was wasting
her time determined she alongside the
foundation and the global occult
coalition would find a way to stop this
thing they would end
scp-6000 reverse the damage it had
caused and save the day
unfortunately this time they couldn't
the entire amazon basin was quarantined
by project fusillade but it didn't
matter
scp-6000 just kept growing and growing
and growing soon after a bm class broken
masquerade scenario transpired meaning
that the foundation and the goc were no
longer able to contain the secrets of
this anomaly as more and more of the
western hemisphere was consumed by
scp-6000
the anomalies object class was upgraded
from ketter to apollyon as goc command
and the o5 council realized that the
ship had officially sailed on its fight
for containment and for the future of
planet earth as the wanderers library
continued to consume more of the planet
in the following days the priorities of
project fusillade shifted focus from
containing
scp-6000 to getting as many key figures
and anomalies as possible off of earth
or out of our dimension all population
centers goc bases and foundation sites
were considered lost it was over the
serpent had won one person who didn't
flee with all the others was director
moose with the prognosis being that
scp-6000 would consume the entire world
in the next two weeks moose decided to
go down with the ship spending her last
days on a dying earth with her final
prisoner
scp-6000-a the snake woman tried to
comfort director moose in the face of
the end she told her that all there
really is in life is a collection of
stories one ending is the beginning to
countless others the end of this earth
this foundation would simply unravel
onto more splitting like a thread's end
into infinite narrative possibilities if
moose could only accept this she would
not see this as an ending but as a
wonderful new beginning a possibility
for more stories that's why the library
was making all these new empty bookcases
there would soon be an abundance of new
knowledge to accommodate and fill its
shelves still moose seemed mournful
about what she saw as the end of her
story the end of the world she asked six
thousand dasha whether her attempts to
stop everything had been pointless from
the start if this ending had always been
set in stone six thousand dasha
responded the point was the same thing
that it's ever been to make new stories
where there was once nothing be happy
tilda your story is going to be
remembered forever how do you think till
the moose responded did she say you
think people will read about us or
rather did she ask what if i don't want
news stories we'll give you a moment to
think about it are you ready the answer
is
it doesn't matter because regardless of
what director moose said it would have
ended exactly the same way if this tale
teaches you anything it should be that
you really can't choose your ending you
can only choose how you react to it
director moose looked up and realized
she was no longer inside facility 57 she
was in the wanderers library staring up
at an infinitude of shelves that
contained an expanse of books that were
both boundless and immeasurable she was
surrounded by people and entities of all
shapes and sizes wearing robes browsing
the new collection and she recognized
all of her old foundation friends and
colleagues among them director moose's
story had come to an end but what she
had failed to grasp was that the end
didn't just mean death it meant the
start of something new new worlds new
dimensions new canons new anomalies a
vast infinity of stories and from inside
the wanderers library with everyone
she'd ever known she could enjoy them
all the wanderers library and the
serpent's hand hadn't killed her they
had saved her
this was director moose's happy ending
and also the ending of scp-6000
but what if this wasn't the end what if
instead
tilda moose had chosen a third option
and responded to 6000-a's comment about
her story being remembered forever not
with a question
but a statement
stories on stories perhaps if she had
answered this way then she would have
been swept away from the world that was
dying around them to somewhere new and
not just one world but many where she
could have the chance to see a utopian
version of earth where anomalies were a
part of everyday life their powers are
part of the fabric of society where
disease and suffering had become a thing
of the past she may then have seen
alternate versions of her own story
where she remained a member of the
serpent's hand until the very end or
even another where she was a member of
the o5 council these were all stories
running parallel to hers and ours real
yet untouchable all she could do was
watch these realities knowing that she'd
be unable to help or interact with the
people she saw just as as cp 6000-a had
only been able to observe ours but in
the end that was okay
because there was always another story
to move on to
someone else's story to become invested
in something else incredible to see
because just like in the wanderers
library
the end of one story only means the
start of so many others